proper search engine optimization or seo
can make or break your website it can
put your website on top of everyone's
mind or let it be forgotten on the 10th
page of the google search results on
that note hi guys welcome to this
complete seo tutorial by simply learn in
this video we'll be covering some of the
most important concepts related to
search engine optimization we'll talk
about keyword research google analytics
google tag manager how you can rank
number one on google and youtube how to
increase youtube subscribers how to get
traffic to your website some popular seo
tools and finally some seo tips and
tricks first off we'll have an
introduction to seo by our instructors
rob and matt welcome my name is rob
sanders i'm a course instructor at
simplylearn today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
seo and seo is search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also may as hear us say
organic listings we're going to talk a
little bit about why you'd want to rank
your website in organic search okay what
is search engine optimization then we're
going to follow that up with how does
google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of seo so
let's get right to it and talk about why
seo so we're gonna use a basic example
and let's just say you have a blog
you're a food blogger you're passionate
about food and your niche is ice cream
and let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am i not
ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a lot longer than
you when they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people who are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice cream blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just may mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called the meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say response to
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank websites and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank the those pages that they've
indexed from number one to infinity
depending on how many pages are relevant
to that search query so really it's
about crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and
what these bots do is they go to your
web server and they're going to crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links you might have
heard the term spiderman but that's what
they call search engine spidering so
basically what google's doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following and so when they
can follow all these links on your
website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index so based
on this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then they're not going to show up
for relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i could see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're gonna
see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google is able to crawl simply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going appear in the
search results so in the example i gave
was simply learn we'll simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their pages the page load time is
fast meaning these pages load very fast
for the end user and google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in india the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the united
states why because google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're gonna see different results now
if you do a search for cafes in mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two google
search engines in india and united
states google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same exact time you do
that search so location is important
language is important and relevancy is
important along with user experience so
all those are important factors in how
google ranks websites okay so we're
going to talk about the types of seo now
so if we want to rank for a particular
keyword on google we're going to have to
apply search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page seo and off-page
seo so first we're going to talk about
on-page seo so on-page seo is nothing
more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do
is understand what keywords we want to
rank for in order to understand what
keywords we want to rank for we need to
do keyword research and if you do
anything in seo keyword research is the
most important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example of how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google is going to do
is they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that that appear
for both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months i could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here i can see google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the google's keyword
planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that i might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing specialist social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30
per month on average and so what i want
to do is get a more clear picture of the
competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when i do that
i get a different result here i can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax
hall in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building on a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist uh learning
paths explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
an h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to
other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when i say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other keywords in the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
on page seo is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there's two
types of site maps one is an html site
map and that's designed for humans so if
you have a website with a lot of content
at the footer or the bottom of your web
page you probably want to have a link to
sitemap so if somebody clicks on that
site map they're going to be able to see
all the pages on your website structured
in an organized manner well an xml
sitemap and xml is just a different
format it's designed for crawlers and so
the whole idea remember is google likes
to crawl content when they crawl content
they bring it back to their servers and
index it and so we want to be able to
create a site map for google or other
search engine crawlers and so xml is the
format so let me show you example of how
that looks so if i go to simplylearn.com
and simply type in say sitemap.xml
just as an example i'm going to get this
particular page and this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these site
maps are there for google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind seo you want to be able to
have google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page seo which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url
the headers choosing the right keywords
to put into the content having internal
linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on-page but you still need
off-page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to off
page seo and so off page seo is simply
the process
of linking or promoting your website
using link building and so if you
remember i talked about this earlier on
there's two types of links internal and
external linking and so for on-page seo
we used internal linking for off-page
seo we're going to talk about external
linking and external linking allows us
to improve our website's recognition or
relevancy or credibility and why do we
want to improve our relevancy and
credibility and trustworthiness and
authority because we want google to know
that our web page is trustworthy it is
recognized by other websites and it is
relevant for a particular keyword and so
if we can do that using off page seo
methods then google's going to rank our
web page for the keyword we want to be
found for so it's really off-page seo
synonymous with link building and
there's plenty of opportunities to do
link building it just comes down to
creating a strategy so again some of the
benefits to off page well we talked
about you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank but there's
some other benefits there so if we have
a link on another credible website then
it's likely going to increase the
traffic to our own website it also
creates high domain authority and so
what i mean by high domain authority is
if we have basically links to other web
pages pointing back to us then basically
our domain authority is going to improve
and when our domain authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher authoritative we are
for our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits its drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website linked back to ours why because
the content
is original it's natural it's well
structured it reads well and so that's
the whole idea behind off page you can't
have links on other websites if you
don't have quality content so one of the
ideas behind off-page seo is not only do
you want to create good content but you
probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to desserts related
to cakes related to food in general
related to vegetables or other items
that people could link from so the whole
idea is understanding who else is out
there who has relevant content that you
could share so you could share your
content with them they can share their
content with you and generally that's
how it works naturally anyway in the web
sphere if somebody likes your content
they're going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content somewhat of yours so that
you can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo what is on page seo what is
off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords for page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one or two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand
the volume and the competition for each
of those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a keyword that has low volume
high competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural
and google's gonna be able to pick up on
that so we wanna maintain some level of
quality with our content and quality
with the keywords that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end user it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something i didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're gonna write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
seo and off-page seo then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user-friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly well to get
this conversation started
here's a preview of what matt will be
talking about today keyword research and
search trends
seo friendly copywriting content
optimization website and landing page
optimization content trends analytics
and of course we'll be answering your
questions throughout so feel free to
chime in so with that
i would just like to
hand the mic over
for a bit here to to met so take it away
mr bailey all right well thank you dan
and as you can tell by the agenda it
seems to be content heavy
and that is certainly uh without an
accident there that if you've been in
seo for any length of time you can see
where things are moving the digital
marketing industry
or social media content marketing those
types of things
and so
the role of the seo is becoming more
critical than ever in being that
connection
from what are people searching for
and then
what do we publish
seo is that critical link between the
research
and the development of content and
that's is only going to increase more
and more over the next few years so
that's why there's a little bit more
emphasis on that content side that
you'll see there but just you know a
little bit more in detail on that that
the role of seo
has primarily been as that
the first line of understanding what the
search engine is doing what do they
require
what are the new technologies coming out
of search and what are the trends coming
from search
how is google changing results what are
they testing
so seos first and foremost are on those
front lines of
seeing what especially google google is
pushing the the envelope more than
anybody and they're testing more things
and so understanding
what is google doing what are the
implications of it uh is this just a
test or are we moving what's the bigger
picture of what they're attempting to do
and
so understanding
that role there of being that early
predictor of what's going on with google
and then being able to translate that
inside your organization or inside your
agency
that is really becoming part of
you know the the representative role of
the search engine optimizer is
understanding here's what's happening
and here's how we're supposed to react
to it
at the very base level it's
understanding those keywords it's
understanding
what are people searching for
and what is their intent
and how do we then apply that into our
content strategy
so that has been really kind of the
foundational
part of what an seo does
but it's also going to
be a little bit larger into looking at
the larger trends of what is google
attempting to do what are the
implications and how do we respond to
that
now of course
with part of that keyword research is
understanding the long-term trends uh
over a year two years three years
because if something has a trend and
it's predictable
well then that's something you can bring
into your organization
because i i love to say if it's
predictable it's monetizable you can
make money off it if you know that it's
going to happen every year because you
can prepare for it you can help your
organization prepare for
those increases in traffic especially if
you're able to tie those trends into
specific events
if you can come up with causality what
causes those to happen how do we react
to it how can we develop that and how
can we incorporate that into our
strategy again that is more of a
planning and prospecting
work that a search engine optimizer
would do
and those
skills of doing keyword research and
understanding the long-term view of
keyword research of trends throughout
the year
creating those connections
that is a valuable skill which is only
going to increase
and of course
those keywords are important for
anyone in a marketing field or also
customer service we've seen more and
more
of this
cross-marketing view across an
organization where marketing is getting
more involved in customer service
they're getting more involved in loyalty
they're getting more involved in
many different aspects of nurturing
customers the customer experience
and so
whenever you're planning any of these
things for social media and what are we
doing with social media are we educating
are we rewarding are we trying to look
for
new customers
well all of that requires content that
content is going to have to be
researched as to when do we talk about
certain things and how do we talk about
certain things
keyword research gives you that agenda
it keyword research tells you when
people search for certain content and
also the associated words that they have
and so that applies to your content
marketing your social media marketing it
also applies to when
people become customers and if you do
any amount of crm marketing email
marketing or email automation or even
triggered your keyword research can help
in developing the content that will be
in those emails because you'll have done
the research and find out what do people
want
after they make a decision after they
purchase a product what are the needs
that they have what is the information
need that they have
and how do we write towards that so
again seo is influencing the content
that is generated by the entire
organization in nearly all
communications
this gets back to seeing the trends that
are happening within the search engine
and you've probably seen this lately i
love this example here so if i want to
make a latte and i type that into google
this is what's interesting the answer to
my question is at the top of the page
now without even going to the website
i can have my answer
for the question
and now there's a couple implications to
this
yes it's great we can be at the top of
the rankings we can have our answer
there
but if the answer completely answers the
searcher's question
it doesn't generate a page view they
don't see much of our brand
they aren't in
really they aren't engaging with us at
all they're engaging with google
and so
this gets to the point of how do you
then bring this to the organization as
far as a strategic view of this how do
we approach it how does this change what
we do with our website or with our
content
you can also see here that
people are asking different questions
and this gets to the copywriting of the
website are you generating content that
answers questions because this is where
google is pooling this information as
well as pulling the related questions
that come from that type of content
this also is critical because this then
leads into voice search
and so if you've got a home assistant
you use any of the phone assistance or
guess what this is coming in cars
that you will have a voice assistant in
cars and your search result will be read
back to you
and this is
the beginning stages of that that if you
have a question or a search you would
speak your search and then the first
result would be read back to you and as
you can see it's not coming from the
site it's coming from google so this is
where again we sit down we look at the
strategy what are we trying to do
what is our strategy as far as
visibility in the search results
and
what's going to happen and what's
happening now with this is you could be
answering people's questions and never
knowing it
simply based because google is
delivering the result they're not going
to your site now the possibility of them
going to your site exists
but as more voice searches are being
generated
google is going to deliver a result that
doesn't require a click through because
it's all happening through audio
so hopefully this uh doesn't uh
all the changes in seo
i would say over the past uh
15 years have been largely external
driven by google as google has taken
away keywords taken away
keywords and analytics
done numerous things here that have
caused seos to have to react
and again this is one of those changes
uh that causes us to sit and figure out
how are we going to deal with this
change we have some questions already
one of which is google's not spending so
much time focusing on keywords
specifically even though they're still
important where do you suggest that
marketers look for keywords
i think the the typical
keyword research tools are still very
viable in fact you'll probably get
better information out of keyword tools
then you will google's keyword tool uh
google has been combining
keyword concepts under a single
keyword so for example um a great one
that uh we've seen in the keyword
research uh pool table and pool tables
plural and singular
google puts that all under pool table
whereas anyone who
you know does any amount of e-commerce
can tell you there is a world of
difference between people that search
for plural and singular
before the the changes in keywords i
could tell you with numerous sites that
we had that if people searched with the
singular version
uh they were about three to five times
more likely to purchase than if they
searched for the plural version
the plural version meant that they were
shopping the singular version
pointed to they were ready to make a
decision
so
google won't show you the data however
between the plural and singular for pool
tables
other keyword research tools however
will show you that
so even though
you know
even though it's getting more difficult
with the keywords from a marketing
standpoint
absolutely still do your keyword
research write as if you would
uh
you know
you're gonna have to do additional
research maybe you know customer
research
uh you know face to face
asking them to describe how they would
search or what they were looking for or
what problem you solved
because you're going to need a wider
variety of input for keywords
yeah and if you have any way to look
into your competitors i know there are
some tools that let you let you do that
you can see what
your competitors are or at least in
their or their sem you can learn a lot
yes
because
you can you can tell a lot by what's a
valuable keyword by learning what your
competitors are paying for
and
uh also check your particular analytics
to see how people are actually finding
you
uh what's interesting is how is uh how
is right i know right brain is one of
the most influential parts of google now
and i know that that's basically a lumpy
instead of creating separate pages for
plurals and
other iterations of words rankbrain is
just sort of uh
including all of that and looking for
those words in general content is that
how is rankbrain affecting
uh
search terms and and seo with just
keywords
um you know it's it's really trying to
learn
more of
what exactly do people want
uh from an intentional standpoint
so
trying to put together
uh
unfamiliar searches or unfamiliar
phrasings or i i think i read the other
day
um i'm trying to think whose name it was
but it was oh matthew mcconaughey
his name in one week had
like 8 000 misspelled variations
so
somehow
you know
a search engine has to figure out over 8
000 misspellings who did you mean you
know who are you trying to figure out um
you know so it's it's trying to figure
out the intent and deliver the right
result and
you know
i think part of this is yes they don't
want seos to be focusing on individual
words
[Music]
and by taking away all that data
you know in a way they have accomplished
that
so
you know what rankbrain is attempting to
do is trying to tie those things
together of
how do we figure out now they're looking
at the minutiae of the difference of
words but they do not want to show it to
us
right so it's not a whole lot you can do
it it's just
you know it's from their standpoint the
best thing you can do is just continue
to write
great content that people want
that answers their questions using a
variety of
using a variety of words that explain
uh you know a great example is you know
if you're writing an article uh you know
baseball season started here in the u.s
if you're reading an article about
baseball you're going to use words like
umpire like balls strikes bats teams
those are all words that build context
and so
they're going to count just as much as
the primary term baseball and in fact
google's going to look for all those
other terms
that that build that context and so it's
it's not so much that single word
anymore it's that variety of
i would call those second-tier words
that support the context of what you're
writing about grows are coming more into
play yeah and and of course putting that
in a and a more natural language
type of uh type of phraseology in your
content rather than yes the old days of
keywords you know how many keywords can
we stuff in the first paragraph
what's the optimum number of words in
the in the meta tag
i mean because now it really
if it looks like you're i mean this
google's been penalizing people for
doing stuff like that for years but now
especially with rank brain
the more you can do to look to write
like a conversation that people are
actually thinking and asking about i'm
sure is a better way they've always
wanted that i mean that has always been
google's goal from the beginning they
have told us to write for humans
uh
but the problem has been you know there
are a lot of seos there that would
rather take the formulaic approach
and
you know why should i write for humans
i'm just trying to get people to my site
you know i wouldn't they're going to buy
and so they you know try to reverse
engineer everything to come up with this
formula
of use this keyword this many times in
this part of the page and
you know
whereas google has always said write for
humans first and so by taking away some
of those
other options or taking away the
keywords
it's really guided the industry to do
what they wanted to do and honestly i
think it's
it's a good thing
because the quality of content has to
increase it it has to get better
and that is one way that they've
enforced that
exactly what they've imposed their will
on on people who desire to have better
rankings right
the uh i just have one one more question
that people a lot of people are asking
if you have any specific recommendations
for for keyword research tools before we
wow
there are a lot of them um so if you've
got like
raven or
um
trying to think what are some of the
others raven seo tools
um there is one right on the edge of my
tongue
tracker still word tracker yeah um
oh
i've got a list of them somewhere here
yeah just look just google out and look
at some of the keyword research tools um
there are a lot of them many of them
offer free trials and so
yeah just get in do the free trial take
a look at what's there
um
yeah yeah some come with full service
site management you may not want all
that you may you may want that others
are more standalone independent they
just do keyword research
never choose a keyword research tool
that
doesn't show up at least on page 10 of
the serps
[Laughter]
but yeah and and honestly the more you
do keyword research i i've always felt
this way and it's the more you do
keyword research
the better equipped you are to do your
job
uh and and by that it's dissecting the
keywords what are people looking for
what are the trends what do they
associate
what are
uh the people places and things
so as you're looking at the keywords
you're not so much looking to see the
volume that someone searched for
you know buy uh you know buy a pink car
that's that's a great you know that's
good but they talked about cars they
talked about buying and they talked
about color that's more of what we're
looking for is let's start slicing and
dicing this down
what words are they associating what
colors what
uh
features and
by understanding the breadth
of how people search and the questions
they have it helps you write better
content because now you understand not
just optimizing for one word
people have questions across an entire
breadth of type style color uh place uh
city uh
you know all these types of things and
so that's really what i challenge people
to get out of keyword research is
understanding
the full breadth of what people want
rather than just a single word or a
single phrase
this gets into copywriting you see like
i said when you when you get into
you know are people looking for colors
are they people looking for locations
sizes i want to understand the breadth
of what they're talking about and that
helps me become a better copywriter i
can understand intent if i know the
questions that they have
then we can write answers
and so
you know i want to see how people are
searching you know a great example is is
now we've seen searches increasing for
people searching for you know the best
or the top rated or
uh the reviews i think is yeah
oh yeah for me uh people are actually
typing in what is the best car for me
and i think what they're doing
essentially is is directly asking google
you know based on the two million things
you know about me what would be the best
car for me
um so people are looking for more
personalized information uh so what you
can do is get into the you know the how
to the why
the
you know what it means all these
different
cues that people are giving in their key
phrases
develop your content to answer those
questions yeah i had actually seen a
statistic that 82 of smartphone users
use
and this is for businesses
looking for businesses use specifically
the term near me after their search so
even geographically um i don't know if
that's anything you can include in the
content but uh well no you know it's
it's blows my mind because um if they're
on their smartphone they're
automatically going to get results near
them
that's
kind of interesting so
it's more of a cue for google than it is
for a website because to use that phrase
and any of your
optimization really wouldn't make a lot
of sense
because you don't know who's near you
and if anything especially on a mobile
search google is pretty much going to
ignore that near me because you're going
to get the results near where you are
anyway
yeah so yeah getting into the search
data people search for what they need
they
they figure out what they're looking for
but now here is where the role of the
seo is going to come in organizationally
is that when you have people writing
content generating content for content
marketing for social media
especially if you're working with
you know like a publisher who is
constantly developing content
now you need to help them
come up with ways to measure success
and also to motivate them to implement
seo tactics in their writing
so rather than
developing catchy headlines
that may have a double meaning that may
not play well in search
you need to help copywriters understand
that well your headline while that might
look great on print
in search it's actually going to cause a
problem and so you turn into an educator
for your content developers uh you're
teaching them what works well what's
going to click well what's going to look
well in the search engines versus what
might be confusing
also
uh it's also helping them to understand
you know a great example of this um
before i move on
someone
um
gave me a great example is they were
writing an article about holiday time
travel and that was the title of the
article that they put out there and they
couldn't figure out why this article was
consistently getting
hundreds or thousands of visits a month
uh well after it was published and when
we went back and started looking at some
of the rankings and some of the keywords
and things like that we found out that
the article was ranking really well for
time travel
even though the headline was holiday
time travel uh so it's helping your
writers understand um you know
what makes a good title uh but then also
one thing that i worked with one
publisher and one of the things we did
to motivate the writers
was to develop like a a leaderboard of
whose content is generating the most
visits
uh and not only that whose content is
generating the most new visits to the
website uh and then you can carry that
through to
you know for how for different writers
how many visits or views have you
generated in a month or over the past
six months how much has your content
performed compared to other content and
you can carry this all the way out to
you know which writers had the highest
amount of ad clicks
in their
articles uh which articles uh led to
people to
uh
subscribe again or you know even get
into customer lifetime value uh there's
so many things that you could implement
so from an seo standpoint you understand
already how to look at the success of
game rankings and what it generates in
terms of page views click throughs time
on site uh click depth uh
you know all those types of things that
you can then develop into helping others
in the organization who publish content
start to measure the impact of their
writing
organizationally and then especially if
you're able to tie that to a financial
implication
that shows that this is what it's
contributing towards the business in
terms of revenue
then you become the all-around hero
because you're able to help others
tie revenue to activity
that's great we have someone asking can
this backfire on you for example if
you're starting every headline with
one weird this one weird trick dot dot
dot
if you find that you have a lot of
if your bounce rate immediately starts
going up yeah you have because if you're
waiting for time travel or star wars or
something uh
that everyone's gonna be looking for um
then um uh could that actually
negatively affect uh how google sees you
if it's if you have all these bounce
rates they might see you as uh no longer
being relevant
absolutely and it's not just google with
the bounce rate it damages your brand it
damages your credibility i mean it's
it's click bait and
i mean
it doesn't take long for people to
realize click bait is clickbait
you can just
look at some of the data
but yeah i mean
when you see
articles or headlines that are
obvious click bait people are you know
you get caught a couple of times you get
fooled a couple of times
it's not always going to work and so
this gets to
you know
how are you positioning your brand
are you positioning your brand as a
trustworthy source of information that
answers people's questions are you
positioning your brand as we give people
what they need what they want
uh
or are you fooling them
to click on an article based on what's
popular right now
uh you know there's a couple questions
that get to how the brand wants to be
perceived in the marketplace
based on tactics like that
but great question great question
because click bait is powerful um but
you've got to ask yourself are we giving
people what they want or are we fooling
them into it and how will that reflect
on the brand
right
from another keyword standpoint one
thing that i found is very valuable to
do is go out and look and see how people
are searching for the brand and
content associations they make with that
brand uh now this can also get into
other areas you may find that there's
some crossover
where
there's another company with a similar
brand name
and so this will help you understand a
little bit more if you get some of that
crossover traffic but also
from a pr standpoint
do people associate content or ideas
with your brand that you would rather
this will help you become aware of
something that might be out there that
may not be getting picked up
so i i enjoy doing these kinds of
searches because i want to know what
other words associations are people
making with the brand right that you may
need to deal with
yeah and also look at your analytics and
what is linked in your crm to see
how people actually converted because if
you have some long tail keywords in
there that would be good to generate
content on uh that your best customers
are finding you through that can be
super valuable and at least compensate
for having some super clickbaity words
accidentally what's interesting is that
people people are are a few people are
really wanting to hone in on this uh
backtrack a bit here too
ways to capitalize on certain things
that um
i know people are looking for quick
answers to rank high on google uh but
the question keeps coming up about for
example if there are there any ways why
you could restructure your content to
capitalize on things like near me like
should you put in your opening paragraph
you know if you're looking for a near uh
that's that's almost i
i personally would would shrink from
doing that because i know that that's
something that that seems that a google
i don't want to put words in your mouth
it seems like hey google is already
doing that automatically based on if
you're searching mobile but two
if
pretty soon they're going to catch up to
people putting
best and near me and because that's the
other question like should i should i
use terms that are
when i when i see the results of
most commonly searched terms and mobile
should i put those in my
in my copy
uh so uh what do you say about that like
are there ways to that you can
legitimately without being uh penalized
capitalism yeah well
okay if you're legitimately publishing
an article that is well researched
comparing
different products and you title it best
pet food products or something like that
that's a legitimate
case i have no problem with that do your
homework
and create something of value
and
it will do well if it's good content
that people like
now the the near me
is
a bit more sketchy because even though
you may put on your website something
about near you or near me
uh
not everyone who visits your website
remember this is more of a mobile
uh phenomenon these are people on their
phone looking for something near them a
drugstore uh a car wash uh you know
something like that a restaurant
and that's being computed based on
distance based on
you know past preferences things like
that
so it has nothing to do with the content
of your website what i would work on
more is your local business listing in
google
and
developing
more reviews for your business
and
working with that
uh listing to
add more pictures
like i said reviews
they have a function there now where you
can add promotions the more you develop
that google listing that will do a
hundred times more to increase your
visibility when someone is looking for
something near them and they are near
you
and adding words to your website
great would that sound smart
i mean come across a bit forcefully on
some of these things
uh mainly because i
it's it has never bothered me when
people out and out try to
fool google with some really intelligent
things uh i
somewhat tend to admire it uh but when
people try to fool google with what i
would call amateurish things that are
poorly executed
that's where i you know that's where i
get
i get a little ticked off at that
because it's
it create a quality experience that's
what people want quality experience uh
and and that's really what it gets down
to when you know we with content
marketing you're answering people's
questions and so
as people are generating that content
you're also sending them back to the
site you're sending them back to get
answers to register to do things like
that so all those web pages from the
content marketing that they're linking
to
they need to be optimized for your
inbound strategy
and what's interesting is also from a
paid search standpoint the landing page
from paid search you know it needs to be
optimized just like any other page
that's part of the quality score
algorithm does the landing page reflect
the paid search headline does it also
contain the keyword that you're bidding
on so
you've got to look at how people are
developing their landing pages
internally and maybe you can contribute
to that as well in helping improve the
quality score because the optimization
of that landing page is very similar
where i see
employment and industry trends now this
is interesting because talking with the
director of omcp
and some of the surveys he's been doing
of hiring managers hr managers and
technology
uh
or marketing across the
across the the globe here one of the
things that he has seen is there is
becoming more demand
of people who can manage the entire tech
marketing stack
not the single channel specialists
because more and more automation is
handling that
uh more and more you know and this is
where we're going to see the entrance of
ai and machine learning is adjusting
your paid search campaign
with those minute
methods of increasing your click-through
rate
uh you know it's going to be managing
those bids so eventually you're just
going to focus more on the content and
eventually ai's going to take over the
content
so
the demand is for
who were the single channel specialists
of seo paid search social to move into
understanding the entire omnichannel
digital marketing campaign
and can run and can change and can make
recommendations across the board for the
entire stack of digital marketing
this is where we're seeing more of the
employment trends uh going as well as
the skills demand
is
getting away from that single hard skill
to understanding the entire campaign
and that's going to go into all
different types of things that's going
to include email crm social display uh
and seos i think are probably very well
positioned in all of these things
because of the foundation of keywords
the foundation of keywords and
understanding intent and then developing
content that answers those questions
that's needed in email it's needed in
automation it's needed in social and
display you know especially in the crm
automation is someone has to write the
content that needs to be automated and
so again this then gets into
uh looking at the trends uh because
automation you not only need to write
the content but you need to
then plan the content when is it sent
when is this completed when is this done
uh and so understanding the
the sales cycles and how long they go
and when people need certain information
at what times it takes that planning
strategy of being able to do that and i
think seos are well positioned to
understand that full stack of marketing
and the implications as well as the
management of it
and then we get to analytics uh this is
my favorite
um
so as an seo or if you're taking on more
of the the omni channel burden here uh
you've got to develop those measurements
that show how effective
not only seo has been but now content
management content management is big
everyone is moving towards it it has
become a significant piece of strategy
however what is lacking in content
management is the measurement how do we
know that this content piece that went
out whether it was a video uh whether it
was an infographic whether you know
regardless of what it was number one how
do we track performance number two how
do we know it affected anything
number three
what was the pathway where were we
driving people and what did we want them
to do and how successful was that and
then also from an attribution standpoint
did this lead to other things you know
where did this content piece or where
does this channel help us overall in
attribution in driving new leads or
nurturing people along the path and so
it's getting more than just getting you
know measuring clicks it's it's
measuring actual hard dollars that were
generated based off specific channels or
specific pieces of content uh and then
you know it's developing an
understanding of sales goals what did
the sales department need uh
information to enhance the crm so that
they can nurture people along in the
path uh so it's more than just marketing
it's understanding that full scope that
a company has
yeah that's a it's an excellent point
and i think another thing to keep in
mind too is is use actual conversation
with your salespeople
as a one of the few things it's funny
that that marketing and sales often are
their own little silos and
i i think one of the best things a
marketer can do is just go and talk to
your best salespeople and ask them
what
why are people buying us
what are the what are they what are the
questions they are asking you to answer
um i think that can be uh because those
questions
since they're legitimately people that
are that are engaging with their sales
people and making purchases i think
those are the most valuable questions
you can answer in your copy oh
absolutely i mean short of talking to a
customer talking to your sales
department is the best way to get
information um it now my
before i got into seo i was in sales i
took sales training and and you know
dealt directly with people so it kind of
i had that uh
you know that view of things
but
i i'm amazed at how much people don't
interact with their sales department in
order to learn
uh you know what do people need how do
we answer their questions what you know
what do they respond to but then also
your sales people are the first in line
entering information into the crm and
when leads are created through your
marketing efforts
it'd be good to ask them what additional
information do you need that would make
a better lead
you know
there and there are many times where we
have changed the site
on the recommendation of the sales team
and
you know we we may not have it we didn't
improve conversions but we what we
improved were
the
the scenario through which the sales
call then came
after the conversion and increased the
close rate just based on changing the
landing page or the thank you page after
the registration
right and it's it's a good conversation
to start having with your sales field
too so that they know what kind of
questions to listen to because a lot of
times they're just not paying attention
you ask a sales person
they made the sale because i was a great
sales guy um
but the more you the more you
work with them as a team and say that
hey you know to get them thinking about
actually listening to what the customers
are asking for and passing that on to
you you know and that of course will
will help lead attribution and and
all the things you said so yeah
definitely
don't forget the human element in seo
well and this gets to
you know this really gets to it
if the trend now is moving more towards
you know someone who can manage a full
stack it's also moving towards people
who understand how to align sales and
marketing goals
and beyond that it's not just you know
like the example i gave before it's not
just okay we increase the conversion
rate of our registration
okay that's great would how did that
contribute to revenue
but now it's understanding that there
are things that we can do
to increase a close rate
that don't always take place on the
website but it's a process
and so now we're analyzing processes
that can be done electronically
and then how do we create a better
revenue stream that way how do we make a
better nurture process
now we're getting into the effectiveness
of content and producing a result
rather than just you know a conversion
uh a sale or a lead now we're looking at
well how do we make more money based out
of this uh and that's really it's that
big picture of understanding that
you know our job is not just to get
leads it's to create better
profitability which rewards everybody
so it's understanding those touch points
from content uh you know so as content
is being pushed out does it answer the
question does it lead people to the next
stage how quickly does it lead them
there uh can you measure influence from
your content and you know through depth
of visitor to the depth of the page that
they got to
um and then again it's
the experience based on motivations
can you understand that can you
tie together what a customer was feeling
at a specific point through their
nurture stream uh or through this
process as i said it's getting away from
more just stuff that happens on the site
it's communications throughout the
entire process the entire life cycle of
a customer that's all coming under
the the management really of the
marketing team right now is that entire
customer life cycle communication and
management
and finally this is something a trend
that i've been seeing as well in terms
of
jobs and hiring and also business
function
omcp did a a survey at the beginning of
the year asking people where they spent
the most amount of their time
and specifically in seo and seo managers
uh and
uh
anyone who dealt with seo
nearly 40 percent of their time was
spent
uh presenting
their research
presenting strategy
as well as uh
as well as explaining their the
reasoning for that strategy
and so seos you need to become a lot
more comfortable in front of people uh
presenting your findings making
recommendations presenting opportunities
trends uh and presenting it in a
persuasive
format
that shows
not a bunch of data charts but shows how
smart you are in creating new revenue
opportunities for the company
and that is really where we see a lot of
things going are the presentation skills
are becoming part of the demand
for companies
when they're dealing with tech thanks
guys now we have rob to take us through
keyword research google analytics google
tag manager how you can rank number one
on google and youtube how to increase
youtube subscribers how to get traffic
to your website some popular seo tools
and finally some seo tips and tricks
keyword research so
what are we going to talk about when we
talk about keyword research we're going
to talk about why we would do keyword
research for seo we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so jessie is planning to
publish a blog of pizza recipes so
she was doing pizza recipes step by step
piece of recipes with sausage homemade
pizza toppings pizza dough recipes thin
crust pizzas she's doing a lot of
different topics on pizza recipes well
what jesse needs to do is understand
what's going to drive traffic to these
blog posts if she's writing about you
know different topics around pizza
recipes so
she's unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take
care and choosing the keywords to align
with your content so that's really the
idea why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they could
have slow search volume for example you
may choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic high competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care in choosing the keywords to me
that's the most important step with seo
is keyword research so we're going to
talk about the types of keyword research
then so we have short tail keywords and
we have long tail keywords so if you
write a blog post about pizza recipes
well what are you going to choose a
short tail or long tail so let's talk
about short tail keywords first so short
tail keywords are keywords that are
usually three keywords and a phrase or
shorter in some cases it may be two
keywords in a phrase or shorter so short
tilt keywords usually have high search
volume which means likely means higher
competition but what it also means it
could be
lower conversions because short sale
keywords like for example pizza recipes
could be considered a short tail key
word but maybe somebody's looking for
homemade pizza recipes or pizza recipes
from their favorite italian restaurant
so
short-term keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with
long-tail keywords chances are you're
going to have lower competition that's
one of the benefits but you're also
gonna have lower search volume but with
longer tail keywords the keyword is
probably going to be more relevant with
the content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rates likely
gonna be higher so that's really the
difference between short tell keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords are broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content as not
relevant versus long tail keywords that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes it could take you a while
to rank for that keyword but when you
rank you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long ticket
keyword is probably going to be greater
because not many other websites are
trying to rank for that same keyword and
so the benefit of that is if you have
let's just say homemade pizza recipes
with mushrooms that's a long tail
keyword but if somebody's looking for
that type of pizza recipe then you know
you're going to track the right traffic
and chances are that traffic is going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that'd be another example more than
three key words in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipes so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more uh specific in nature
longer tail so these keywords are used
for targeted pages including blog posts
if you're writing a blog post
specifically about pizza recipes with
homemade dough then this is the keyword
you likely would want to use versus just
pizza recipes so let's look at an
example between a short tail keyword and
a long tail keyword and to accentuate
the differences we're going to use
google's keyword planner tool so
google's keyword planner tool is located
in google ads the google ads platform
and when you're in the google ads
platform you can simply click on tools
and then keyword planner and so what
keyword planner allows us to do is get a
sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what google's
keyword planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and what
google's gonna do is it's going to show
us the volume of those keywords so for
pizza recipe we could see the average
monthly search volume is 33 100 for
pizza recipe so note that pizza recipe
and pizza recipes are closely related
keywords and so what google does is they
consider that a close variance so
meaning if somebody types in piece of
recipe then they're also in google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33
100 queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here i
can see for this particular keyword here
the volume per month is 33 1 000 and
then i can see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword i can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variance
homemade pizza dough recipes i can see
over the past 12 months what the search
volume is for this on average is 2 400
but i could see here in december the
volume went up to 3 3600 but for example
in may it was 1900. so it's going to
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average it's about 2400. so
shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what google's
keyword planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here i can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2 400 search queries for that keyword
now whether you get all 2 400 clicks for
that keyword remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2400
you're going to get a lion's share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
google's keyword planner tool in google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2 400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all 2
400 but are we gonna get a line share
that we also need to look at competition
and so google's keyword planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what i want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
google's keyword planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
i want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what i can do is go
into google search and i could type in
pizza recipes and i could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so i want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
i'm going to put in the all entitle
syntax and so what that is going to ask
google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if i
do all in title colon space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000.
so what that tells me is that there are
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if i want
to focus in on my other keyword if i
choose uh my other keyword
was a longer tail keyword homemade pizza
dough recipe so if i type that keyword
in the homemade pizza dough recipe or
recipes remember close variance and i
just click enter or type the keyword in
and hit my enter key i'm going to get 35
million results but again is that really
an indicator of the type of competition
i have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so i'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then i'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and i get
2160 different results so here i can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites and web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now i have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about seo
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for seo and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000. so i'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes
so if i go back for this particular
keyword is 2400. so i'm going to put
2400 in under my volume column and then
what was my competition well my
competition was i typed that keyword
back in
2160. so i'm going to put
2160. so now i have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition i
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number keywords what you
do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if i make that a
percentage i can see it's 0.35 percent
is the ratio between volume and
competition if i do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
i can see that 111
so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah i'm still going to get some
volume but i have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say you know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
google's keyword planner tool in the
google ads platform we want to target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the google's keyword planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over and we can
get a sense of any particular trend
going on or seasonality so for example
if i saw large growth in the winter
months and not much volume growth in the
summer months then that might indicate
to me that this keyword is more popular
during the winter time so pay attention
to the graphs that you know the keyword
planner tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny halloween costumes well we know
that for halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
september all the way through october
and then it's going to drop after
october 31st which is halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
google's keyword planner tool to find
the volume we use the all in title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 in google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement's going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples are commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't be afraid to
use some of these keywords as part of
your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for seo so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary and search okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool google's keyword
planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if i go in to
google's keyword planner and type those
keywords in i'm going to choose get
results and now here i could see healthy
diet plan keyword i'm focusing on as my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900
and then some of my secondary keywords
healthy diet foods diet plan weight loss
low carb diet you know google will give
me a number of different keywords to
work with so i'm going to look at the
search volume of that as well and so
ideally what i want to do is be able to
then look at the volume and then look at
the competition so healthy diet plan i
go into my keyword analysis here that's
my theme so that's my keyword what's my
volume for healthy diet plan
9900 what's my competition so my
competition is 74
700 and that's going to give me a ratio
of volume to competition of 13 so that's
what my contents about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13
and what i want to do is i want to be
able to put these other secondary
keywords in here as well maybe even go a
little longer tail because i want to be
able to
find to keep at least two keywords i
want to be able to find my primary
keyword that's relevant to my content
and then i want to be able to find my
secondary keyword which is again related
to the primary keyword which is also
related to the content and so i want to
be able to choose two keywords basically
and i want to choose two keywords that
are relevant that have good ratio
between volume and competition so that's
the whole idea again on how to do
keyword research you want to be able to
find your keywords use the tools
available to you and get a sense of what
the volume is what the competition is
look at the ratio between the volume and
competition and then based on the
content choose that primary keyword and
then again based on the keyword you
chose choose some secondary keywords as
well because you want to be found for
not just one keyword but multiple
keywords okay let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account lsi
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like cora or reddit we can use
google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
lsi keywords and lsi stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are lsi or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to google search
for example if i type in healthy diet in
google search all i need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and i can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top google's also giving
me some other suggestions here so
they're saying low fat diet veganism
gluten-free diet so there's lots of
different suggestions right in google
search bar so all of these are lsi
related keywords if you're optimizing a
page for a healthy diet then you could
choose low-fat diet as a secondary
keyword you can use gluten-free diet as
a secondary keyword it really depends on
what the content is but you always want
to support your content with as much lsi
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in google search so it's
important because if you have a blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so
google for example uses lsi keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on python and your content you want to
support that with lsi keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for a feature snippet for
example maybe you know healthy diet
recipes if i type that in you can see
here there's a featured snippet so if
i'm talking about recipes that's a
keyword i may want to use and if i use
that then google has an opportunity to
see what my contents about and place my
information at the top in this featured
snippet you can also again see what some
of the questions are being asked what
males are good for weight loss what is a
good healthy diet plan all of these can
be keyword phrases that you can use so
the answers are right here in google so
core is a great platform because core is
a platform that people go and ask
questions
and a community responds with answers or
responses to that particular question or
topic and so the great thing about core
is it's a good i it's a good place for
you to go to get some ideas about a
specific topic so if we're talking about
healthy dieting so we can find keywords
with high search volume right in core so
the whole idea is you can look at you
know the top five questions for specific
topics like healthy dieting and find
relevant keywords to healthy dieting so
if you just type in that particular
keyword in quora you're gonna probably
get some responses to questions or
responses to somebody else's question
and so if we take a look at core for
example so if i just type in healthy
dieting what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get some responses to
the topic healthy dieting so what's the
best diet for healthy living what are
the top five tips for a healthy diet
habit so all of these could be keyword
phrases that you could take away with
for your own content and so the benefit
here is you're getting kind of an idea
of what's trending what people are
talking about and if you use tips for a
healthy diet habit for example and you
optimize for that well again that could
turn around and bode well for you
because you could be featured in google
as a featured snippet at the top here
you can also turn around and use lsi
related keywords for healthy diet habits
and you can simply just look for those
lsi keywords right in google remember at
the bottom or at the top if i scroll
down i could see some related lsi
keywords at the bottom so writing google
as well
you could see in the google search bar
that google provides some lsi related
keywords to your query so if i go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes i
can see here google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for men healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
lsi related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about lsi keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in google just by doing some
additional research within google itself
or on quora so according to google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for a term so google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if i go back to
google again if i start to type in
recipes i could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet google is going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in google itself i could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes i can also get
the search volume by going into google's
keyword planner so if i type in healthy
diet i'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition i can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if i'm looking for healthy diet
google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are lsi related keywords that google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the google ads platform
another option for you is wikipedia so
wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we could take a look at keywords from
the wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional pages like the see
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so we go
to wikipedia as an example and i type in
healthy diet
into wikipedia here i can get just in
the first paragraph alone i can see
some additional keywords that i might
choose to use like micronutrients i
never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe i can use
that as a keyword an lsi related keyword
to my content so if i scroll down i get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
i can look at categories like dietetics
and diets i can also look at the
references section so i can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
i can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to
my main keyword healthy diet so the
answers are right in here on the
platform they're just all over the page
so wikipedia has an abundance of
information you just need to know where
to look so again with wikipedia you can
look no further than the first paragraph
you look no further than the see also
section the references section category
section there's lots of information
right on the page itself to help you get
ideas for keywords so if you google your
keyword with wikipedia term in the
search query and get relevant keywords
from the title tags on the serp so you
can also do that as well so if i type in
healthy diet wikipedia in search i can
also get some information here as well
so people also search for healthy food
advantages or healthy food habits essay
or information about healthy food all of
these are related to
my keyword healthy diet so again another
bit of information for you to choose or
look to choose some additional keywords
for so reddit it's a popular community
where
people post content and discuss a
variety of topics so that's what reddit
is so with the help of subreddits an
individual can find relevant keywords
with with high search volume so in
reddit there's an easy way to find out
keywords they have a keyword tool called
keyword it so keywording is the average
monthly searches for a particular
keyword so if we type a word in qredit
and choose keywords from the
auto-generated list this tool will
extract the keywords and give us those
relevant terms with search volumes so if
we go to the keyword it and show an
example of that for example healthy food
if i get keywords i can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if i just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
keyword planner tool and google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
target just one keyword when we can
target many so keep in mind you know lsi
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is seo how does seo work intro to seo
what are the basics of seo all of those
are related to the core theme what is
seo another cluster of keywords for
example could be seo techniques seo best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page seo techniques etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in themes and
if we group keywords together in themes
we can apply that to a particular
content on our website so the whole idea
behind clustering keywords it's going to
provide more diversity more of an
opportunity for us to be found so that's
the whole idea behind clustering so some
additional steps remember stay up to
date on industry news so brainstorm your
ideas first and identify a list of
keywords i.e a theme of keywords that
you can cluster together and then you
could determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword seo best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword moz if
i go to keyword the keyword explorer
tool in moz and just type in seo best
practices
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is it's going
to show me
what pages are already ranked for that
particular keyword so therefore i can
get a sense of who is already ranking
for that keyword so here i can see
mozmosmedium.com
alexa.com so i can get a sense of what
web pages are ranked for particular
keyword or group of keywords i want to
rank for myself so if we look at tools
for keyword research look no further
than moz that's the mods of the tool i
would just use but you could also use
google's keyword planner which we used
in the example so for example if i go
back to the google ads keyword planner
if you're in google ads you click on
tools you click on cleveland planner and
what keyword planner does is it provides
you for a particular keyword the average
monthly search volume over the past 12
months it provides you information on
seasonality so if i hover my mouse over
a graph i'm going to be able to see the
volume per month over the last 12 months
what the keyboard planner also does is
it provides me some additional ideas for
my particular keyword and in addition to
that it's going to provide me some sense
of how competitive that keyword is by
telling me whether it's low medium or
high in terms of competition so there's
sem rush there's also other additional
keywords tools out there like word
stream or href or the reddit tool
keyword it and then moz is is another
tool i particularly use so if i go to
moz again here i can just type in a
keyword that i'm interested in it's
going to give me the search volume of
that keyword it's going to give me the
level of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so
it's halfway between difficulty and easy
and then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if i were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what i like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular keyword we're interested in
so here i can look at the top 10 list so
this is moz's keyword explore tool so
that's what this tool is and it's part
of moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal i particularly use moz i
particularly use google's keyword
planner and those are the tools i use
but there are lots of tools out there
google analytics i'm very excited to be
with you today because google analytics
is one of my favorite google platforms
and my favorite topics so let's talk
about what we're going to cover today
and we're going to start out with how to
set up a google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the one prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a google analytics
account is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so once you actually sign
in then you're gonna go walk through a
series of steps but really that's really
all you need to get the account going is
a google id and login so if you have a
gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new google analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the url for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because
that's when the day starts in analytics
and the day ends based on that time zone
so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is to
allow google products and services so if
you opt into this then basically what
google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
i would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs in education and because you've
opted in it's going to do the same exact
thing for you it's going to share
anonymous data on other websites in the
same industry and the benefit of that is
we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically google allow google access to
your account and they'll be able to help
you if you occur or run into any issues
so these are the options in setting up a
google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few fields note that
we talking about a website right now so
i'm talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection i'm going to click accept
once i accept i'm gonna be able to get
some tracking code the tracking id is
the id associated with your account and
so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's going to be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up
demo.simplylearn.com if i wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then i can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property i set up in that account is
going to have a dash one dash 1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now this snippet of code needs
to go on every page of your website that
you want to track and you don't have to
put it on every page but if you want to
track website behavior on every page
your website then it needs to go on
every page of your website so if you're
using a you know platform like drupal
or joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in to wordpress
for example and then just simply plug in
in the id now there's an alternative to
adding the google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's google tag
manager so google tag manager is the way
i would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with google tag manager i would
recommend watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube type
in simply learn google tag manager and
this will give you a nice overview of
what google tag manager is and how it
works but basically this is the way i
would go and i would recommend that in
addition having google analytics you set
up a google tag manager account and then
that way you can put the tracking code
in google tag manager so if i go to
google tag manager and i just go into an
account on tag manager i can just simply
put in the google analytics id right
into tag manager and so if i have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way i don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if i
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
google analytics id associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on youtube for google tag
manager that's the route i would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
google tag manager or through a plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
google's going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm going to have then access to
the demo account from google and google
analytics so i would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a google account
and if you have a google account and you
add the demo account to your google
analytics account you're going to be
able to see
how analytics works okay and so that's
what i would also recommend so if you're
not ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
simply add the demo account and then
once you add the demo account you're
free to peruse around google analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you do actually
set up a google analytics account you're
going to have some settings that you're
going to want to pay attention to so
when you set up the account you have the
account name and then you have a
property so under each property you have
by default you're going to have one view
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demo simply learned so
that's associated with the website we're
going to track and then again by default
under each property you're going to have
a view and so by default the name of the
view is going to be called all website
data and so in that view is where all
your analytics data is going to be
stored so you can see my screen here
there's a lot of different settings you
have you have settings under the account
you have settings under the property and
you have settings under the view so
we're going to talk more about these
settings in future webinars for advanced
google analytics users but for now know
that there's a bunch of settings that
you have that you can play around with
when it comes to google analytics
anything from adding users to your
google analytics account your google
analytics property review you can
actually set up goals you can set up
filters you can set up segments you can
link up google ads you can
you know set up remarketing lists
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so no those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you can
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to
choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report and i
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users i actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here i can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here i can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what content
they're looking at on my website so i
can see currently have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see what events
are firing so here i can see we have
event tracking set up and i can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here i can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
gonna be able to see them highlighted so
if something gets fired it's gonna get
highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see we have goal
number four has already had one active
user and so if i look at the last 30
minutes i can see i still have only one
goal over the last 30 minutes and that
was somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting in summary it
just gives you an idea of what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally if i'm launching a
campaign or let's just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving then real
time is a good option for you so you can
see how things are happening in real
time now let's jump down to audience
reporting so if i click on audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
gonna see a number of different reports
available to me under audience and so
let's click on the audience overview
report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name a social security number
credit card information etc however we
can still paint a nice picture on who is
coming to our website meaning what
country
city or state did they come from what
language what device did they get to our
website from how old were they okay were
they male or female or other what
interest did they have what browser did
they use so we can paint a nice picture
based on all this information that
google analytics is providing us under
audience so if i go to audience overview
here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak english and are from
the united states okay in fact that
represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so
if i have a 100 of the users i could see
61 of those users represented english
speaking users from the united states
seven percent represented english
speaking users from great britain and so
when it comes to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the google
analytics tracking script to your
website what's going to happen is if a
user or when a user goes to your website
they're going to get cookied if it's the
first time they've been to your website
what google analytics is going to do is
store a cookie in the browser so when
that same user comes back another day in
the same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here i can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here i can
see april 6 through april 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here i could see about 23 24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience so if i
skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year i'm
going to choose the last 30 days i'm
going to click apply now i'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here i'm looking at the last 30
days and i can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender i
can see
represent males so i can get a break out
of gender and age as well as interest
and click on interest and look at the
overview there and see what the interest
is of the users who are coming to my
site based on in-market segments or
affinity i can also choose language and
location so if i want to know exactly
where my users are located when they're
coming to my website i can click on
location and here i can get a breakout
43 percent of the users of the last 30
days were from the united states more
importantly i can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here i can see if i have an
e-commerce website i can see of those 43
percent 0.29 of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so i can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if i click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports i tend to spend a bit of time on
because i want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
google demo website i can see mobile
represents approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact via mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so google
analytics is telling me that yes i have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if i
look across this report i'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if i'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile i can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case from mobile landed on a page
they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
percent mobile in desktop it's a little
bit lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5 now if i look a
little bit further in engagement i want
to be able to measure how long somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough i can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
commerce conversion rate is at 0.29
percent that's higher than desktop at
0.07 it's lower than tablet but it's
higher than desktop and mobile has the
most transactions and since they have
the most transactions they have the most
revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something i definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if i click save
i'm going to enter a name for this
report i'm just going to call it mobile
report and click ok and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if i close that up you can see
audience real time customization if i
click on customization if i click on
save reports i should be able to see my
save report here and i do so here i can
see mobile report if i click on it i can
simply go to the report i was looking at
before i saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature in analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we were setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and i recommended
you do so and so if you did actually opt
into benchmarking then you're going to
be able to see
how your site compares to others in the
same industry so if i click on
benchmarking and then click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare my website with others in the
same industry so if i go back to say
jobs and education
and i choose education all education as
my industry vertical i should be able to
see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how i compare with those
websites so i'm choosing all countries i
can narrow that down if i wanted to i
can just search for the united states i
can choose a specific state and then i
can choose a particular site size so
here i'm choosing sites by daily
sessions so these are sites that have an
average of 5 000 to almost 10 000
sessions a day and so in this vertical
education in the united states sites
that have 5 000 to 9999
sessions per day that means that there
are approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria i chose now if my site
is similar meaning if i'm in the united
states if i'm in education and i'm
receiving 5 000 to
99999 sessions per day then i'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now google's sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's shared
data anonymously in particular
industries and verticals and so now i'm
looking at a channel report so if i want
to see how i compare to others in my
industry
then i can go ahead and see by channel
for example am i driving as much traffic
as others in my industry and you can see
i'm not in fact i'm 76 77 percent worse
in terms of the amount of traffic being
driven from organic search so anything
in red is going to
show as a negative result a negative
comparison whereas something in green is
a positive comparison so if i look at
engagement i can see that i might not be
driving as much traffic but i can see
that the pages per session are better
than the site average or the industry
average i can see if i go over again
looking just at organic search i can see
the bounce rate is better than the
industry average so the channel report
under benchmarking allows you to measure
how you compare to others in your
industry and you could do so by looking
at location and devices so if you opted
into benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how
users whether they're returning or new
came to our website and so what
analytics does by default is they have a
number of default channels and when we
say channels we mean analytics is
grouping different channels based on how
users got to your website meaning how
did users get to our website did they
come via organic search meaning did they
type something into google and find you
in the organic listing analytics also
groups users based on whether they came
to your site directly meaning did they
type in the url directly into the
browser or did they bookmark your
website and come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning do they come from another
website they group users by social do
they come from a social media platform
like twitter or facebook if you're
running paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say google then do they come from paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say google's network google's
display network that's a default channel
so analytics will group users there so
if they don't recognize a channel then
they're gonna group it as others so by
default google analytics groups users on
how they came to your website via these
default channels and so i can see how
many users came to the site from each
channel now if i want to drill down on
this report i can click on all traffic
and then if i click on all traffic i can
go to channels i can look specifically
at the channels report and so now i can
see organic search again over the last
30 days
is the number one channel driving
traffic and they represent approximately
again you can see this number here in
parentheses next to the raw number of
users i can see that number is about 56
so 56 of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the
audience reports when it came to mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to
behavior we can see conversions and
since we're running an e-commerce
platform we could see what the
conversion rate is by channel so organic
search did drive the most traffic and
they did have the most transactions over
the last 30 days and the conversion rate
in this case is 0.17 okay so how google
determines the conversion rate they
basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions so that means that over
the last 30 days organic search drove 38
123 sessions and of those 38 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in revenue so i'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
i can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by channel you'll
also get a summary so here i can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so i could see over the last 30
days i've had 54 000 users 49 000 of
them were new okay that meant that at
those 54 000 users i had 70 000 sessions
i could see my average bounce rate was
43 percent the pages per session we're
just over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about two minutes
and 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and i had a total 97
transactions totaling 5500 dollars okay
and that's all over the last 30 days so
any report you look at in analytics is
going to have a summary and note that
going to allow you to save it so if it's
a report you think you're going to go
back and look at at a future date then
you simply just have to click on the
save button conversely if you don't want
to save it you can simply just export it
so you can export it as a pdf if i click
on pdf it's going to allow me to export
that as a pdf now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
google sheet you can export it as an
excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see i can
save it as a pdf if i want to and if i
click ok it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then i can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running google ads note that you
can connect google ads to analytics and
this is key because now i can see
how many people are coming from google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with google ads i'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here i'm
running a report based on campaign data
so i could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much i'm paying per
click and you can see on average i'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly i want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see i've
spent 810
over the last 30 days and received 858
in revenue so you want to make sure that
you link up your google ads account to
your google analytics account for this
very reason you want to be able to see
how your google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so i want to see if they're engaging and
i want to see if they're converting so
there are all sorts of reports under
google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting so there's all sorts of
reports under google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if i go to
campaigns i can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
facebook whether it be email whether
that be
you know other types of advertising
let's just say twitter or instagram
you're going to be able to see those
campaigns here and that's under all
campaigns and again you'll be able to
see the campaign name and you'll be able
to see metrics associated with those
campaigns and more importantly you'll be
able to see your e-commerce if you run
an e-commerce platform or if you have
goals set up so you'll be able to look
at how your campaigns are not one not
only driving traffic but two are they
converting let's go from acquisition
reporting to behavior so behavior
reports are going to actually show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website did they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if i go to
overview under behavior
now i'm looking at this graph here it's
showing me how many page views i've had
and a page view is simply once a page is
viewed it's counted as a page view so if
a user comes to my site they're
initiating a session and if they look at
a page then that page is going to have a
page view okay so a user can look at a
page multiple times in a session and
every time they look at that page it's
going to count as a page view so here i
can see in this graph how many page
views i've had again over the last 30
days and if i look further at my
overview report i can see the specific
pages and how many pages they've had and
i can also look at some other metrics
okay the average bounce rate the average
time on page i can look at the exit rate
which means how many people actually
exited or the percentage of people who
exited from that page so i can dig
deeper into my behavior reporting so if
i click on site content and i click on
all pages then i'm going to look at a
report by page this is my dimension this
is what i'm measuring my page and now i
can see how many page views each page
had over the last 30 days now note you
also have something called unique page
views so unique page use is equivalent
to one per session in other words if a
user came to my site and looked at the
home page then the home page is going to
have one unique page view and one page
view now if the user in that same
session looks at other pages then every
page that user looks at it's going to
have one unique page view however if the
user goes back to a to the same page in
the same session then it's still going
to be one unique page for you but in
this case the home page if they look at
the home page a second time then the
home page is going to have two page
views if they look at the home page five
times in one session then the home page
is gonna have five total page views and
one unique page view okay so that's why
unique pages is equivalent to one per
session where page uses accumulation of
how many times the page was viewed in
the same session so in other words
you're always going to have more page
views than unique pages okay so this
gives me a sense of how my page is
performed so again i can look at total
page views and then engagement so
ideally what you want to do with a
report like this is if a user is not
engaging on the page then that should
tell you something about the page itself
if they're not engaging if the bounce
rate's high if the time on page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something with that page now these are
all pages but if i jump down to landing
pages my landing page report is showing
me how many people actually landed on
that page and so here i can see under my
landing page report i can see the home
page had thirty six thousand seventeen
sessions in the last thirty days that's
how many people landed on the home page
so here i can see seventy one percent
were new sessions meaning that i had a
lot of new users who landed on the home
page in fact 25 000 or 52
of the people who landed on the homepage
were new i could see the balance rates
about 42 percent but of those who didn't
bounce they went on to look at about 4.5
pages per session and spent about three
minutes on the site and the one thing i
like about the landing page report is i
can also see whether that particular
page in this case the home page did it
help contribute to a goal or conversion
and in this case i can see of those 36
000 sessions i had 22 transactions
totaling 1200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to
0.06
of the revenue so this gives you an idea
of when somebody lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed's
important because what google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
i would say even under 3 seconds okay
now there are other factors involved
with page load time the browser you're
using the country that you're actually
browsing that page from might not have
the best infrastructure you name may not
even be on the best internet network
meaning you're on a cell network or the
wi-fi is not that great or you can be on
a page that just has a lot of images or
a lot of code that may slow it down so
there are other factors involved and so
what google analytics does is show you
what those factors are so here i can see
by browser what the average load time is
if i want to look at country i could see
what country is contributing to the low
time now the great thing about the site
speed report is if i go to speed
suggestions okay what speed suggestions
is going to do is it's going to show me
the page load time by page and then it's
actually going to provide a link where i
can actually click on to get suggestions
on increasing the page load time so for
example i can look at this particular
page here this google redesign shop by
brand slash youtube page line number
five if i look at line number five i can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if i click on seven total
what it's actually gonna do it's gonna
open up a new window and it's going to
open up another google report called
page speed insights and page speed
insights is going to give me some
information about what i can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at this
site speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load times very important it's so
important that i'm even going to save it
so i'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click ok and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in google analytics
because what the conversions reporting
allows us to do is see how people are
converting or if they're not converting
on our website and so in google
analytics we have the opportunity to set
up goals now you have the opportunity to
set up 20 goals in your google analytics
view and so to set up a goal okay so
you're going to click on admin and under
the view you're going to see goals and
so if you don't even have goals the
first step is to create goals and so you
have four different goal types and
analytics so you have pages per session
so how many pages per session is so if
your goal is set to say three or two if
somebody actually looked at two or three
pages per session it's going to count as
a goal okay so if i look here i could
see i have pages per session set at 10.
so that means that if a user came to the
site looked at more than 10 pages per
session then it's going to count as a
goal another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case i can see here
that the goal is set to this particular
page here and so when somebody actually
lands on that page it's going to count
as a goal now there are two other goal
types we can look at one is duration so
just like pages per session in our
previous example if somebody looked at
10 pages per session it's going to count
as a goal with duration it's based on
time so in this particular case if you
set up a duration goal and the duration
is set to say one minute and 30 seconds
then that means if a user comes to my
website and they spend at least one
minute and 30 seconds then it's going to
count as a goal okay and then the fourth
type of goal in google analytics is an
event based goal so when you set up
event tracking you could turn that event
into a goal so if somebody clicks on say
the submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's going to count as a goal so
you have four different goal types in
google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if i look at goals overview i can
be able to see how many total goal
completions i've had so if i want to
look at it by goal i can just choose the
goal option here so if i want to look at
for example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session i can see
that i had a conversion rate of 10
percent meaning that i had 7 000 of all
the users who came to the website 7 000
gold completions meaning 7106
users looked at 10 pages or more on my
website and so that's how you want to be
able to measure whether users wherever
they're coming from whoever they are
whatever pages they look at you want to
be able to look at the conversion
reports to see if they're actually
converting based on the goals you've set
up whether that's pages per session
duration destination or event goal
conversion tracking reports can help you
measure who is actually converting and
the great thing about google analytics
here is that i can actually see
by segment so the default segment in a
segment is just looking at a specific
user set so the default segment is
always all users however i can choose a
different segment so if i want to choose
instead of all users if i want to choose
mobile traffic i can select mobile
traffic hit apply so i'm actually now
looking at a subset of data i'm looking
at mobile traffic so if all the mobile
users have come to my site i can see
1400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a seven percent
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate of each goal
but you can also change the segment of
that particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report i like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report so if i click on
multi-channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here i can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if i look at
three channels direct organic and
referral i can see all three together
drive two percent of the conversions if
i look at direct and referral 12 and a
half percent if i look at direct and
organic 12.24
so i can see how different channels work
together and so if i look at top
conversion paths as an example i can
actually see
what channels how channels work together
to drive the conversion so in this
example i can see over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
times 2 meaning that somebody came to
the website directly meaning they typed
in the url in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then convert it so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure
if that channel actually did contribute
at a later point and in this case we
could see organic search drove traffic
that didn't convert but that traffic
came back a second time via direct and
did convert so that's our second best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only our channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns and different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely going to
have more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today google tag manager
thanks for joining and let's get started
with this simply learn webinar so let's
start out with
ygtm so let's just say you're sam
and you have your own e-commerce website
and you want to understand how people
are interacting with your website well
sam today's world of websites contain a
lot of interactivity everything from
videos to pdf downloads to commenting to
form submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so
really what gtm does is they help you
track all these things i just mentioned
everything from somebody clicking on the
play button of a pdf to somebody
clicking on the submit button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function so that's what gtm is so
why gtm because it helps us track all
that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to really place a
piece of java code which is just script
and the script that's added to a web
page to collect information so that's
really what a tag is it's just some
script that gets put on a web page in
order for you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third party tools okay so that's
what gtm does it it basically allows you
to take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in gta
so
if you want to for example
collect how many people
you know enter
a
chat functionality and start chatting
well you're going to take that script
and you're going to put it in gtm and
gtm will then allow you to start
tracking that information so that's
really what gtm is it just allows you to
put tags into a container or think of it
as a toy box you have all these toys and
you want to track well you can put all
those those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into gtm let's just say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your web page and you want to update
the tag well your developer considering
it's probably a small update your
website is probably gonna not um
hesitate and is gonna go ahead and turn
around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer's
gonna go to the website and update the
tag well what if you have a few things
that you want to track all those things
i mentioned before from downloads to
clicks to
you know somebody checking out to
watching a video well your web master
your web developer is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time i need to put
them into the work queue so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue usually it's going to take
some time and
in some cases you as a marketer need to
launch a campaign and you want to get
that tracking uh added to the website in
time for the campaign launch so you want
to go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer's
like well i need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
is my point and so that's where gtm
comes in because there is a solution
update your tags faster and
that's google tag manager so when we say
gtm that's what gtm stands for google
tag manager it's a place for you to add
tags quickly and easily so tags remember
are just snippets of code that allow you
to track things on your website
interactively interactive activity and
basically when you have gtm you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so
that's what gtm is all about so why gtm
because we just identified two benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website and two
you can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and so that's the benefit of
gtm so the benefit you get those tags
updated very quickly via google tag
manager okay so that's what tag manager
is so what we're going to talk about
today is specifically what tag manager
is and what it does we're going to list
some of the benefits of tag manager
we're going to show you how it works and
then we're going to show you how to get
started with tag manager tag manager if
you're not familiar with working with
webmasters and dealing with javascript
and tags and all this jargon is just new
to you today okay well don't fret sit
back we're gonna take it slow this is an
introduction into google tag manager
again let's start out with what is tag
manager so we've already introduced it
to some degree because we already
introduced is a tool where you can put
all your tags into a toolbox toy box or
container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if i'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can i
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a google tool
hence the name google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
is deploying track tags on your website
bypassing your webmaster so that's tag
manager and so examples of tags that can
be deployed via google tag manager are
numerous these are just some examples
like google analytics facebook pixel
tracking or google ads there's no limit
into the number of tags you can track in
tag manager there is no limit you can
add any number of tracking tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
javascript codes quicker so remember
these javascript codes or snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
page view or somebody clicking on a play
button or tracking somebody who converts
or even just goes to your website so the
biggest benefit is you can take that
snippet of code let's just say facebook
let's just say you're doing facebook
marketing and you want to put that
facebook pixel on your website so that
you could track people who come from
facebook and convert well you don't need
to put that facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager really quickly and
the other benefit here is all tags are
managed in one place and that's that to
me is really a good benefit because when
you start adding tags on your website
and you have some tags in tag manager it
just gets very confusing so ideally all
the tracking code you have on your
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing bing or you're doing facebook or
you're doing twitter or you're doing
linkedin and you're doing google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're gonna
have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting on that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you wanna put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
gtm for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version it's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a piece of
mind so to speak just because you've had
code to your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you could track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and i'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already i'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking code you
have in gtm or you can have somebody who
is very familiar with tag manager and
can go in and add the tracking code to
tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag manager work because you're
like rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and javascript and
versioning and publishing and all this
other stuff well i know i'm throwing a
lot at you at once but just bear with me
here okay so let's start talking about
how it actually works so you have a
website okay whatever that domain is you
have a website and there's chances are
on your website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
google or facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also drive traffic to
the website so in comes google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that facebook
campaign or that google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running facebook and you are running
google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so google analytics being a
google product works very nicely with
tag manager facebook has its own
tracking code and but you still want to
be able to track people who come from
the facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if i add
facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say i had google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
manager is controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
i am i'm in tag manager i just went to
tagmanage.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so here if i look at all
the different tracking code i have on my
website through tag manager let's just
take a look at google analytics so if
you're going to use tag manager you
might as well put the google analytics
code in here so here i can see i have
google analytics as a tag in tag manager
now for facebook if i'm running a
facebook campaign well i can take that
pixel tracking and put it in gtm as well
and here i could see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to gtm i just
basically took what facebook gave me and
put it into google tag manager so you
can see i can add facebook and google
analytics and again i can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform i can add to google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so i just showed you an example of how
you could take facebook and google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember i mentioned toy box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's gonna
go into the toy box or container and so
the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if i take
my facebook tracking code and put it
into a container i need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager i'm going to have an account
and if i have an account i'm going to
have a container so here i'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's google analytics that's
easy here i can see i've google
analytics added so if i click on google
analytics
here's my tag and if i take a little bit
of a deeper dive there since google
analytics is a google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy i can just choose
google analytics then i'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so i need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
google analytics tracking code so in
this case i'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if i get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is i have a
tag and i need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if i go back
here you can see facebook well here's my
facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell gtm when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the javascript code
that you get from say facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so
variables are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common use
variables include say page path or page
url or host name or click class again
they're there and these examples i just
gave you are there to get your tag and
trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if i
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side i can see variables so
remember i have built-in and
user-defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case i need to get my trigger to work
with my tag i can use a variable so
those are built in and then i have user
defined so these are what i define these
are what i created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that javascript code okay in the
case of facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
i click on adwords remarketing again
it's a google product so i don't really
need to even deal with code i'm just
going to select google adwords
remarketing okay so you could see gtm
integrates nicely with some of the other
google products but let's just say you
have a facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling gtm when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell gtm when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of javascript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it and even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag and the trigger is there
because you need to tell gtm when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the url
equals facebook.com or some other
condition so the tag cannot be created
until the creation of the corresponding
trigger so tags and triggers go together
you can't just create a tag and not have
a trigger otherwise your tag will never
fire and then the variable is there
again it stores the information when
defining a trigger or transferring data
to tag so a variable has a variety of
data okay so you pick and choose the
variable you want to use with that
trigger okay so you're making sure that
by defining a variable you're making
sure that you're telling gtm how that
trigger should be fired so let's take a
look at another example here of how all
three play together if i'm in this
account i'm in this container if i look
down here i can see google optimize
that's another google product so
what i'm doing here is i just chose
google optimize as my tag it's already
integrated so what does that mean i
don't even need to deal with any code
i'm just going to select optimize well
we have the tag google optimize but we
need to tell gtm how to fire that and so
here we're going to tell gtm to fire it
on all pages so that's basically a very
simple example because we're firing it
on all pages so if i want to look at
something specific again facebook here's
my tag here's my code what's my trigger
well my trigger is it's going to fire on
specific pages how do i know that well
if i look at the trigger here i could
see the trigger is a page view but i'm
telling it to fire on this particular
hostname so the tag and trigger go hand
in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager and you're going to create your
account and then when you create your
account what's going to happen is you're
going to
set up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
ios or maybe android or you can even set
it up for amp etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
going to happen is you're going to get
some google tag manager code in return
and so the whole idea here is you're
going to do a swap what you're doing is
basically you're saying okay google i'm
going to take this google tag manager
code and i'm going to put it on my
website i'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is going to go in gtm
okay it's going to go into the container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing i wanted to mention on the account
is it's a google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say google
analytics or some other google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
google analytics right to google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're gonna be asked to place code
on your website and when you place that
code on your website then you are free
to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
okay so if you want to know more
information about installing google tag
manager then what i would recommend is
visit the quick start guide website of
gtm so again if you're curious as to
where that code is located in google tag
manager well when you create an account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific id
so if i click on that specific id here's
where i can get my code okay so again
when i'm logged in to tag manager i'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation i'm going to see my
unique gtm id if i click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed i'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so basically what you're gonna do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what i would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website i would recommend
setting the first tag up as google
analytics so that will get you going
with tracking page views on your website
when some when somebody visits your
website okay so ideally that's what you
want to do you want to get google
analytics as your first tag and tag
manager so what i'm going to do is
because analytics is a google product
it's already integrated nicely with tag
manager so i'm just going to click on
google analytics it's going to be a page
view that's what i'm tracking and now i
have to set up a variable and so what
it's going to do it's going to ask me to
sort of select a variable and so what
you're going to do is you're going to
select new variable and what you're
going to do is you're actually going to
go and add your tracking id here that's
going to be your variable so where do i
get my tracking id and analytics well if
i'm in analytics i'm going to go to
admin and then under property settings
i'm gonna see my tracking id and all you
need to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you gotta copy over
that tracking id then you're gonna go to
tag manager and paste it and then that's
gonna create a variable for you and then
when you create that variable you're
going to see it in the drop down here so
i've already created it and
basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
i have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if i get a visitor to any
page on my website then i want you to
fire google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking id and so you get the tracking
id again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking id over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking id so you
could set up the variable and then
basically that's what you need to do
okay you're going to add that tracking
id and then voila that's your tag with a
variable and then once you've done that
then you're going to click submit so
when you click submit you're basically
saying hey i want this tag to go live
now this tag and trigger and once you've
done that then analytics is ready to go
and anytime somebody goes to your
website on any page tag manager is going
to fire google analytics so the great
thing here is you have something called
google tag assistant and that's an
extension that works with chrome and so
when you've actually added tag manager
to your site or you have analytics
running in tag manager you can confirm
if those tags are firing properly so
let's take a look at how google tag
assistant works okay so if you just do a
search for google tag assistant you're
gonna see here that it's basically just
an extension that works in chrome and it
unfortunately only works in chrome
browser it doesn't work in any other
browser so go ahead and install that
extension into chrome and when you do
that you're going to see this nice icon
here in your browser and now if you go
to any website and i click on google tag
assistant and i click on enable okay so
basically i'm loading google tag
assistant and now once i refresh the
page i can see that this particular site
has google tag manager installed and not
only does it have tag manager installed
i can see that it's also has google
analytics running i have also google
optimize running and i have google ads
remarketing tag running in tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview
in tag manager so basically that's going
to put me in preview mode and so what
does that mean well that means that now
i'm free to go to my website and see if
those tags are firing and so let's take
a look at what that looks like so if i
go to the website and just click refresh
then what's going to happen is tag
manager is going to load in preview mode
just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now what can i see in
preview mode i could see that i have gtm
firing but i also have some other tags
firing on this page remarketing i have
google analytics i google optimize i
have some other tags firing as well and
so the preview mode shows me what tags
are firing on any given page and i can
also see what tags did not fire okay so
here i have a number of tags already in
gtm but they didn't fire on this
particular page so let's just say i
clicked on the donate now button i'm
still in preview mode so i'm going to be
able to see what tags fired now i can
see i have a couple of tags that have
fired on this particular page and then i
could see what tags did not fire on this
page okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode before you even submit
a tag and trigger to see if it fires and
that's the great benefit of tag manager
so if you're not sure if something's
going to fire or not then you can always
go into preview mode um and if you are
sure it's going to fire then you can go
ahead and submit it so you can leave
preview mode and just go ahead and
submit that particular tag and trigger
so here i'm going to leave preview mode
and now once i'm done and i'm sure the
tag is going to fire and go ahead and
submit all my changes that i've worked
on in terms of setting up tags and
triggers so that's really gtm in a
nutshell so i have my tags okay my tags
are just snippets of code that i'm going
to put in whether that be facebook or
vet tracking or any other google product
like optimize or page view then i have
my triggers my triggers are there to
tell gtm when to fire that tag and the
variables are there to help those tags
and triggers work together so remember
that particular variable we set up for
google analytics okay so here it is
right here because we want to tell gtm
what property to specifically fire in
google analytics so that's why we set up
that variable but there are all sorts of
variables google tag manager has built
in or variables already created for you
or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again i can't stress
that there's an unlimited number of tags
you can add to tag manager there's no
limit so you got everything from
anything from google to non-google to
event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
i want to go back to an older version i
can simply do that so here you can see
i'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and i can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter sign
ups facebook youtube buttons on your
website just like this website does and
you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're gonna need tag manager and
when you have tag manager you're gonna
be able to track all of these button
clicks and interactivity on your website
today we're gonna talk about how to rank
number one on google so let's get
started and um let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but sam doesn't understand why his
website's not ranking number one on
google and so
typically ranked number one on google
there are some factors involved and
those are factors that are going to help
sam get his website ranked number one on
google so he can sell his shoes get
traffic and convert that traffic to
conversions so there are factors
involved and so what are those factors
well it always starts with keyword
research so in order to rank for a
website where you sell shoes or
you sell products other products like
clothing or food or
you're an automobile website you know
you're a mechanic it doesn't matter
whether you're selling to customers or
selling to other businesses you have to
start with the keyword research and so
we're going to go into really explicit
detail on how to conduct a proper
keyword research and then the second
factor involved is high quality content
so in order to rank high on google
search you need to have high quality
content so we're going to go over what's
involved with creating high quality
content then we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on-page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on google then we're
gonna get into the off-site engagement
so when it comes to ranking on google
you need to optimize your website and
you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites and so we're going to
talk about what's involved with offsite
engagement so seo being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule
when it comes to search engine
optimization and ranking on google and
what do we mean by the 80 20 rule well
80 20 means we're investing 20 percent
of our effort and 80 percent of the
results are obtained so we want to
invest 20 and get back 80. that's
basically what we mean by 80 20. so for
example if 20 of our targeted keywords
bring in 80 of the traffic then that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 percent
of our landing pages drive 80 percent of
the overall traffic that's following the
80 20 rule or 20 percent of our
backlinks past 80 percent of our link
juice that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for eighty percent of the results
so without further ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and and it doesn't
really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google it all
starts with the keywords as i mentioned
before and so
in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so the obvious keyword here
would be shoes for kids well every
keyword that you target has search
volume associated with it so that means
when we talk about search volume we're
talking about how many people on average
type in that keyword or related keyword
on google.com or google search and
there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be competition
for those keywords meaning there's
always going to be other websites who
want to rank number one on google for
the same keywords and we call that
competition or difficulty so for every
keyword you're going to have volume and
you're going to have competition or
difficulty and the difficulty ranges as
well depending on the tool you use and
we'll get into that in a minute but
search volume is how much on average
people are typing in that keyword or
close variance of that keyword and the
difficulty is measured in terms of how
many other websites are trying to rank
for the same keyword and so ideally when
it comes to keyword research we want to
find that nice balance we want high
volume and we want low competition but
at the same time we want to focus on
keywords that are highly relevant to our
business so if we're selling shoes for
kids and shoes for kids is highly
relevant has high volume and low
competition then that's a keyword we
want to target so we always want to
focus in on those three areas so there's
always a trade-off with keywords so
shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
google for that keyword and so the whole
idea beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with
long-tail keywords meaning the longer
the keyword phrase there's gonna be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
google ads so google ads has a tool
called keyword planner and let's just
say i have a a website where i'm selling
dried figs and if i'm selling dried figs
i want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them i want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for keywords related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example i'm
going to give here and so if i look at
the keyword planner in google ads if i
just type in bread recipes what google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what i would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if i go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be 60 500. however if i go
back into google's keyword planner
google is telling me the competition is
low so that's great i want high volume i
want low competition but how low is low
so we want to be careful so if we're
going to put in numbers into a
spreadsheet we want to figure out what
that competition really is for the
keyword bread recipes so if i go to
google and just type in bread recipes
i'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all entitled colon
and then our keyword bread recipes we'll
be able to see that there are
998 000 results that's a lot lower than
771 billion so that means that 998
sites or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if i look down and
scroll down here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on google and
so therefore i'm going to put in 998 000
in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now i could see for the
keyword bread recipes i have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my kei
or keyboard effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition
is six percent so that's nothing more
than volume divided by competition so
that tells me that my kei or my ratio
between volume competition is six
percent so remember we want more volume
than we want competition so anytime you
do a keyword research you're going to
find a number of different relevant
keywords so if i go back into google's
keyword planner if i typed in bread
recipes you could see that google is
going to give me a number of different
keywords related to bread recipes let's
just say i have another keyword that i
want to think about optimizing for being
ranked on google for and that's banana
bread recipe very similar keyword as
bread recipes except it's a little
longer tail now if i type in banana
bread recipe in google's keyword planner
now i can see the average monthly search
volume has actually gone up it's 368
000. i can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now i can
see 368 000 i'm going to go ahead and
put that in my spreadsheet now i'm going
to go into google i'm going to put in my
syntax all in title i'm going to put in
banana bread recipe i'm going to hit
enter and now i can see i have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if i
look at the title tags i can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
google search results so that tells me i
have 233 000 results that i have to jump
over in order to rank number one on
google so i'm going to put 233 000 in my
spreadsheet now i can see my kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157 158
and so to me that's a lot better number
to work with or in other words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant and it has a higher ratio of
volume to competition so therefore
banana bread recipe is going to be a
better keyword to optimize for in order
to rank number one on google so that's
the whole idea behind keyword research
you want to brainstorm ideas there are
plenty of tools out there so the tool i
recommend is google ads keyword planner
google's gonna give you how much search
volume they're going to tell you the
competition but then you're going to go
into google search you're going to use
the syntax on title to get a more
accurate read on the actual competitive
number and so to find out how keywords
that your competitors are ranking for
you can use those keyword tools that i
mentioned another tool that i use is
miles so moz if you go to moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword for
example bread recipes it's going to be
able to tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing i would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
reading and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
can stay up to date on industry news to
get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put our emphasis just on
one keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for so the
primary key work and to find the nature
of our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword at the
end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
google for that page so for example we
have a blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat-free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade eyes care
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so
one thing we want to do when we do
keyword research is we want to be able
to target one keyword per content when
you can target many we want to be able
to target multiple keywords not
necessarily target one keyword and so
we want to be able to cluster keywords
so we don't want to target just one we
want to target multiple keywords per
page and when we talk about clustering
if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords into a content
theme so why target only one keyword per
content when we can target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to target just one
keyword we want to target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily going to get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and
when you don't get good engagement if
people don't stay on the site to engage
in the content and they just leave the
website after landing on the page
causing a bounce then the content is
just going to continue to fall down the
rankings and we want to prevent that we
want to move up the rankings we want to
be number one on google we don't
necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we wanna be able to
you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summer time and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so
let's talk about some best practices
here remember in the last segment we
talked about keyword research so we want
to perform good keyword research why
because we want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page one keyword could be
related to our brand one keyword could
be related to the content but another
keyword could be related to a user's
intent like recipes if you recall the
example we use with bread recipes maybe
somebody's looking to type in a keyword
that says how do i make you know a bread
or how do i make a specific type of
bread or how do i make banana bread or
what's the best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where choosing those right
keywords that's going to respond to a
user's intent so starts with choosing
the right keywords so remember we talked
about a number of different tools when
we talked about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called phrase.io and
that will help you do quick research on
you know keywords and trends and whatnot
so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question that's the whole
idea behind content content is not just
to fill a page it's to really fulfill
users requirements that's when you get
good engagement so if somebody's typing
in something on google and they're
looking for an answer your content
should answer that question but we also
want to make the content readable so in
other words you know write for your
audience don't impress anybody with
very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you break
your content into paragraphs keep the
flow organized if we can keep the flow
organized then it's going to be easier
for somebody to read and then it's okay
to add resources especially resources
from credible sites so if you can
incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey i've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to remember when
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we chosen keywords that are going to
answer somebody's question we don't want
to stuff those keywords into the content
we want the content to be naturally
written so when we say opt for white
hack uh techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to
write an article about
how to write good engaging content we
don't necessarily have to write all that
out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the point of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps or rules and they lay
those out all here in this infographic
and the great thing i like about
infographics is you could you could
share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you can save
them on really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need
text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person's engaged so
we're going to rank that favor book so
if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well
with search engines so this is according
to hubspot so the more word count you
use the more words you use the chances
of you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords in your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like easy perfect yeast bread or easy
crusty french bread or something that's
going to be engaging you know the best
bread recipes or how to make the best
homemade bread you know something that's
going to draw somebody's attention to
the title of that blog post so we want
to include lsi keywords so what i mean
by lsi keywords in your content we mean
you know long tail keywords make it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content always stays
relevant to the audience okay shorten
your sentences and paragraphs so don't
write long paragraphs remember we want
to break this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just see from a
bread recipes page to a banana bread
recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the
end user engaged because you're offering
up links that's relevant to the content
you always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to
pan the image with text so that way if
the image doesn't load then at least the
alt text will load so we can incorporate
call-out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action then that's going to keep
somebody engaged and have them act on
your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three month old post on
buzzfeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
in a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and
go ahead and share it if they like it
okay it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's that don'ts
obviously don't lift content we don't
want to lift content from another
website so that's plagiarism so we want
to have our own unique content we also
don't want to take images from other
websites and so if you do happen to find
an image that works for your post and
it's on somebody else's website ideally
that's not a good situation but if you
do happen to do that then always give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from
xyz.com
creditxyz.com for the image and even put
a link back but ideally you don't want
to take images from other websites just
as much as you don't want to take copy
you don't want to take images use your
own imagery and content but if you don't
have imagery then you can always go to
stock photography there are plenty of
websites out there where you can sign up
for a subscription like adobe stock
images as an example you could sign up
for an account and in some cases you can
sign up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience give them to your
audience what they deserve which is the
information they're looking for they're
looking for the best banana bread
recipes give them the best banana bread
recipes incorporate your own images
break it up with titles give them a good
quality piece of content that they're
going to be able to engage with and so
if you put long paragraphs in your
content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on google
search so
let's just do an overview of what we're
talking about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
urls so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank high in google search we
also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on google search so title tag
and meta description together are
considered meta tags so both play an
important role in ranking high on google
so we want to be able to write unique
title and descriptions for each page on
our website when i say unique that means
the title and the meta description need
to be different for every page on the
website and so if you're not quite sure
what a title tag and a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here in
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the url and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's gonna happen is
the
meta description tag or the title tag
will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we could see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
account meta description then google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and into this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond uh based on their
need and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on google it's more action
oriented it's gonna get somebody to
resonate with the question that they
have and that may be their query how to
rank number one on google and so these
techniques will
help you get higher click-through rates
and so according to backlinko
title tag with a keyword can improve
site ranking so remember we want to
include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have 65 characters
we want to include that keyword but we
want to avoid stuffing the keyword in
there we want to again make the title
tag action oriented maybe with the
number maybe as a question with the
keyword in there once naturally not easy
to do but that's the beauty of seo if
you can follow these best practices and
write a good title tag then the chances
of you improving in your search results
are going to be greater so having only
one h1 tag in your post is going to be
good so remember when somebody clicks on
a link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1 tech because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags h tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tags should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
california fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content we'll look no
further than including a video into our
content so not only will this video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page and it's
from a third party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there h2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of h1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden texts we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your h1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here california fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet and breaks up the monotony
of the content and more importantly and
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so according to john muller
senior webmaster trends analyst at
google header tags would definitely help
google for rankings and the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to urls we want to use
hyphens and avoid underscores so if we
look at this url here this uses hyphens
fig and banana bread so it's all broken
up with hyphens that's a best practice
remember canonical urls a canonical url
signals to google this is the original
content so we want to use original
content and if you have multiple sources
of content out there on say different
websites we want to use the canonical
tag to signal to google this is the
original content please index this
content a nut doesn't hurt to use a
favicon url meaning a small icon it
helps to break up the monotony and help
your url stand out we can add targeted
keywords in the url so again looking at
the url here i can see we're using
targeted keyword as part of the url
structure vegan banana bread and notice
the h1 tag is fake banana bread so it's
all consistent and it flows naturally
urls that are no longer existing then we
want to be able to set up a redirect for
those urls meaning a 301 redirect is a
server response for google that says hey
google this page is no longer available
but we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
urls you want to include those in the
sitemap and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that url and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the urls the urls are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lower case from the url
readable urls again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the url
is then google is going to understand
what the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on google search so according
to backlink 2 urls that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
write client google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
children's shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
nike puma adidas on the women's side it
could be nike puma adidas on the child
side it could be nike puma adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy so we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has nike
puma adidas the women should have nike
puma adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and css or html meaning
we want to be able to use something that
google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in html and that's
what google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going and we don't
want to have unnatural inbound things
you always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here i can
see as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well this has an internal
link to another page on our site and
this happens to link to a page where
somebody can buy the ingredients so it's
a natural internal link so john doherty
of credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the credo website is architecture
so for example in credo john dougherty
has increased the organic sessions by 74
in pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised by changing the
site architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure https means it has a secure
license meaning the site is secure so
google likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be http so we want
https
as our protocol and what that means is
just enabling ssl certificates and that
means when you enable an ssl certificate
that means your domain or your protocol
is going to be turned to https so google
prefers sites that are secure versus
non-secure so if you use hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look into
buying an ssl certificate getting your
sites flipped over to https because
what's going to happen is your url
structure is going to change when your
url structure changes google's going to
recognize that because they're going to
index your site and when they index your
site they're going to see those secure
urls and that's going to work favorably
in your favor and help you rank higher
on google search so websites using
secure or https
have a higher chance of ranking higher
so https is a ranking signal because
google indexes those pages so let's also
talk about sitemaps so sitemap is one of
the most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
urls into one file so we're basically
going to
prioritize all our web pages in a
sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if i
type in sitemap.xml
i'm going to be able to see all the
pages in my root directory and i can
also prioritize them i can also alert
google as to how often they change and
every page is going to have a date stamp
associated with it so google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google is going to see that size
that date stamp that last modification
damn so we want to be able to make sure
content's updated frequently we want to
let google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
urls in the sitemaps so we want to be
able to add all our original urls in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
dynamic urls sitemaps for larger
websites and what i mean by dynamic urls
that means that if i look at this
sitemap and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the site map
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
sitemap grow with more urls when the
sitemap grows with more urls then that
means then google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
dynamic site maps is we want to be able
to capture all the urls just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our site maps and so i would
always recommend a dynamic site map but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in xml
sitemaps
into google search here i can see xml
sitemaps generator and i can be able if
i have a small website just create a
free and simple
site map on my own when xml sitemaps
creates it or your platform creates a
dynamic sitemap either way the sitemaps
going to sit in the root directory and
then what we want to do in turn is let
google know where that site map is so in
search console we want to be able to
submit the sitemap so you're going to
add the sitemap you're going to let
google know where it is it should be in
the root directory and it should be
called
sitemap.xml and when you do that google
is going to be able to take those urls
and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 urls google index 521 so
one thing about urls here is when we
create a site map we're putting all your
urls in there we do not add no index
urls in your sitemap and what that means
is that any url we don't want google to
index we're just going to exclude from
the sitemap okay so we want google to
take all the urls we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sitemaps for seo can increase
your website's visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your urls that
you want indexed you're telling google
how often they're modified you're
telling google which ones are important
and you're submitting that to google and
so google is going to be able to take
all these urls quicker index them
quicker and when they're indexed quicker
you can get rent quicker and when you
get ranked quicker you can get traffic
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
sitemaps so let's turn our attention to
page speed now so when the last factors
for our website besides architecture
making it secure and adding sitemaps is
want to take a look at how quick our
pages load here are some tips in order
to optimize page speed because ideally
the quicker a page loads the more
engaged the user is going to be if it
takes a longer time for the page to load
all the elements of that page then
what's going to happen is the user is
going to get impatient maybe leave the
website all together or go to another
page and so we want to be able to
optimize images so any image that's of
large size in terms of megabytes we want
to be able to optimize that to compress
the image so that's one way to speed up
page speed we want to use a simple
website design you know html with css or
cascading style sheets just a simple
design with simple hierarchy and website
navigation structure so nothing fancy
nothing complex just a simple website
design with optimized images we want to
leverage browser caching and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text etc and so we want
the server to respond as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in google analytics so if i
go to google analytics and i go under
behavior and i go under site speed and i
go to overview i'm going to be able to
see what my average load time is for my
site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under four seconds anything
four seconds or higher and it's likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions and google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then google is
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potential
page loads slow and if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see the home page of the example is
loading on average of seven seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if i click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called page
speed insights and basically what it's
then going to do after it's done running
is is going to tell me all the ways in
which i can optimize my pages not only
for
desktop but also for mobile so here i
can see for desktop or for mobile i can
look at some ways in which i can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to p speed
up page load time and all that's found
in page speed insights and all that's
found within google analytics so
remember optimizing code minimizing
redirects optimizing your images
upgrading your server response and all
of those are factors and so again you
can go into analytics page speed
insights and you can see exactly what
google is recognizing as what's lowering
or slowing down your page load time so
google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today walmart as an example
experienced declining conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increase conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page load load time will make a world of
difference in terms of engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
offsite engagement so previously we
talked about on-page elements and
website factors that affect our rankings
for search results but we also need to
turn our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and on to
other websites so that's off-site
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
and i'm going to talk about how to rank
youtube videos today so it's simply
learn we take our videos on youtube very
seriously meaning that when we create
videos we want people to see them
because we know we make good videos and
we know we have good content and we know
that our audience is going to enjoy it
and so we want our audience to see the
videos that we're creating and so we're
going to give you some tips and tricks
and methodology and ideas on how to get
your videos to rank on youtube so
at simply learn if i go to
youtube and i just type in machine
learning you can see where right here is
the first organic video on youtube for
machine learning if i jump over to
google and i type in machine learning
basics you can see where number we're
number one for machine learning basics
under videos if i click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if i look at another keyword data
science interview question okay we'll
rank number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on google search and
on youtube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at uh the machine learning basics video
here and we can see that it has over 221
000 subscribers for this video 234 000
views we've had over 2 000 people like
the video and we have had over 270 plus
comment on the video so when we get our
videos to rank then we can see there's a
lot of engagement and so that's the
whole idea is when you do a video and
you want to show up on youtube you want
people to enjoy you want people to share
it you want people to like it you want
people to comment on that and that's
part of the whole ecosystem of youtube
it's you know we're going to show you
behind the scenes of what it takes to
get your videos to rank and then we're
going to show you some of the metrics
involved with some of these videos to
help you stay ranking so without further
ado let's go into
how to get your videos to rank on
youtube so we're going to talk about
keyword research for youtube we're going
to talk about some ways to create high
quality videos so the importance of user
engagement just as i showed you with the
machine learning basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're gonna get
into how to promote your content and
then we're gonna just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
center our keywords just like our
website we want to center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on youtube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states youtube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
google so
youtube is pretty popular majority
people use youtube search every day to
watch videos on a number of different
topics so they can find these videos in
google but because youtube's so powerful
and so popular people go directly right
into youtube for their searches and so
the whole idea behind youtube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on youtube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on youtube just like for those of
you who watched any of the seo videos we
produced at simplylearn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
first thing is search suggest so youtube
has a feature called autocomplete so if
you've done any searches on google it's
very similar if you're typing something
in to youtube search then youtube is
going to suggest other related popular
keywords so let's take a look at that if
we go back to
youtube for a second and i just type in
machine learning youtube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if i choose you know machine
learning tutorial i'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns ranked
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know youtube
just like on google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are keywords that people are using
to search on youtube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's youtube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to youtube so if i go
to type in simply learn here's their
channel page just by clicking on simply
learn i click on videos ever wonder if
there's so now i can see all the ever
wonder if there's an easier way go back
so here i can see all the videos sort by
most popular once they do that then i
could choose a video this is the most
popular video right now for simply learn
if i click on that video it's
automatically going to start playing but
what i could do is simply just look at
you know the content description so just
by clicking show more i can see all the
content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so
what you want to do is you want to look
at the html and so that means looking at
the page source so just like web pages
what youtube does is they look at meta
tags so if you recall from seo in order
to get your pages to rank you need to
have a title tag and a meta tag
description so videos are no different
what we're doing uh for youtube is
aligning certain keywords with the video
so if you take a look and do a search
for keywords by viewing the page source
you're going to see all the keywords
associated with a particular video so
for example i go back to youtube and i
look at the page source of a video let's
just say this video here facebook's ad
tutorial i'm going to pull up the page
source and all i need to do is control f
and type in keywords and now for that
facebook video i can see all the
keywords associated with the video so
you can see there's a lot of different
keywords we're aligning with this video
and so why do we want to do that because
we want you know our video to show up
for keywords that people may type in and
so if you use that youtube autocomplete
it's going to give you those ideas this
most popular keywords so if they're
related align those keywords with the
video so here you can see facebook
marketing facebook ad strategy facebook
ads for beginners so forth and so on so
there's a lot of keywords we've aligned
here with that particular video and
again all you need to do is look at the
page source so right clicking view page
source do a control f for keywords and
you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you could do that for your
competitors videos as well so you can
see what keywords your competitors using
for a video that's most popular for
their channel and is also ranking on
youtube and on google so using the
autocomplete gives you those keyword
ideas looking at your competitors videos
also gives you some other ideas for
keywords that you can align with a video
that's relevant that you want to rank
for so let's look at uh
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins and there are plenty of plugins
available on the chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples of vid iq and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if i go
back here and i look at a video on
youtube let's just say the machine
learning basics video i have vid iq
installed on my chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid iq is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with facebook
some engagement metrics really what i'm
interested in is those keywords so if i
scroll down a bit here i can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning basics video so vid iq is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated i can also see where they
rank so for machine learning basics this
particular video ranks number one if i
go down i could see what is machine
learning and how does it work i can see
it's ranked number two here i can see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so i can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
i can also see some channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place i want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you
to really get an understanding of what
keywords to use at the particular video
so autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a chrome extension in this case
i'm using vid iq to give me some
information about the video tags for a
particular video so according to an
industry study using keywords and video
tags will help you rank well on youtube
so you have to use keywords and video
tags if you want your video to rank
there's been a lot of studies youtube is
so popular and videos are so prominent
in today's world where if you have
videos and you're going to upload them
to youtube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on youtube or google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third party
extension in chrome in my example i use
vid iq that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what google's
going to do and youtube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition are
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on youtube just like the
machine learning basics so if i go back
to our video our machine learning basics
video if i just type in machine learning
basics i'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if i click on it i'm going to
go to youtube and so here i can see this
keyword we know humans learn from their
is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's aligned
as a keyword tag with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction
machine learning primary keyword is
machine learning basics and then we
supported that video with those
secondary keywords what is machine
learning because somebody who doesn't
know machine learning is probably going
to type in that keyword and then
introduction of machine learning is a
good secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics of what machine
learning is all about so primary keyword
machine learning basic secondary
keywords what is machine learning and
introduction to machine learning so
that's the whole idea behind choosing
keywords you want that keyword that
really is going to define the content
and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
google shows on the video results page
so what i mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on youtube it's
also to be found on google so if i go
back to google and i just type in data
science for beginners and i type in
videos then you can see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on google search you can always
just when you do a search what google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall
for data science for beginners but we're
ranked number one in the videos category
and so somebody's looking for a video
that's important and you can see here
that these first two are ads so what
google is doing is they're saying hey
this is so relevant this particular
video for the keyword query data science
for beginners that we're gonna show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on youtube and google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on youtube are going to be instructional
based and so what google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video titles so we want to
use our target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title youtube has a limit of a
hundred characters so we really have to
pick and choose a really wisely so if we
look at the video that we were focusing
on a couple of minutes ago so machine
learning basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really google and youtube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
high click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if i go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey i don't have
time to watch a video i only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great i'm gonna click on
the video and now i have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember click-through rate is clicks
divided by impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up in
the search results on youtube or google
so we want to keep our click-through
rate high and in order to do that we
want to be able to write some really
good title tags for our video so use
catchy words like a number or how to or
what is because that's going to resonate
with people when they're searching now
for the description what we want to do
is we want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if i go back to
my video here machine learning basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if i look at the description
of the video here i can see this machine
learning basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if i go back to my video i click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if i go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if i go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's
aligned with that hashtag and then
there's target keywords and lsi keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example i gave a few minutes
ago we used the facebook ads tutorial as
our example here i could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those lsi related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as target keywords with the
video so between your lsi keywords
target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on youtube so just doing these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to us youtube itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid iq the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on youtube let's our turn our attention
to creating high quality videos and some
of the best practices around that so
along with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords this is a primary factor in
ranking so in order to have keywords we
need to have content and in order to
rank we need to have you know good
content so let's talk a little bit about
creating content and what's involved
with that and what we really mean by
high quality videos so if you have a
video content that is not informative or
relevant to the topic it won't rank so
that's just common sense so you need to
create content that's aligned with the
topic obviously and then that way you
have keywords that are in line with the
content so but if you have content
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not going to rank no matter how
much you've optimized that video so just
keep that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here so high
quality content is determined by
really two metrics so we're not sure
about how good our content is and how
good of high quality video we've created
we want to look at audience retention
and user engagement so audience
retention is simply the percentage
length of your video that the audience
has watched it's the percentage your
audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but got to
keep in mind content so content is
related to audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so yours are engagement
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so
what do we mean behind longer videos so
what's the reason for longer videos
let's just suppose we have two videos
one shorter in length and one longer in
length first video is 15 minutes long
the second video is seven minutes long
so on average if viewers watch about 40
of both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long we'll have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that region is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to
watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has
higher watch time than the other watch
time is just the number of views times
the average view duration so another tip
is we want to plan our video script so
we want to keep the content organized my
recommendation is you know create an
outline first and once you create an
outline of how the video is going to
flow then start populating with content
and so to me that's how you can keep the
flow organized okay is really with an
outline starting out with it on holidays
no videos are no different than say a
presentation if you've done a powerpoint
presentation you always want to start
out doing an outline then we want to
upload high resolution videos high
resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link oaks more than 50 of
videos on the first page of youtube are
high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
and they're expecting to learn about
machine learning and what it is so if it
meets expectations then the chances are
that person who's watching the video is
going to watch it longer and that means
it's going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to
create high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like i
am i want to i'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning basics
video which i've done throughout this
session i can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning basics well the
title is online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that i'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to
use high quality images in your video
give more information to your audience
giving maximum relevant information can
help gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from youtube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on youtube itself but
you know when you want to create a video
yeah you can create another video about
what is machine learning but just make
sure it has your own take on it you're
the subject matter expert when creating
the video create it with your own
original content have high audio quality
and video effects so just like you see
here on this video we have effects in it
and the audio is of high quality meaning
no background noise no distortion and we
want to be able to speak clearly in the
video so you want to speak clearly
loudly concise just as i'm trying to do
now so that you can understand what i'm
trying to say or what the viewers trying
to to understand when they're watching
the video so watching and listening are
two of the components and you want to
make sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content to go along with the video that
outline i referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video okay focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out all
together so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so
we can look at audience retention in
youtube so use the options above the
graph to view absolute audience
retention or relative audience retention
so audience retention is basically how
many views a video received and the
percentage of the total number of video
views and that includes every moment of
the video as a percentage so we'll show
you an example of what that looks like
so here if we go to the machine learning
basics video we can look at the audience
retention report and this is since it's
been uploaded the lifetime audience
retention so here we could see a nice
graph the percentage of people who
viewed it and how long they viewed it so
in percentage so here for example i can
see you know 43 44
watch the video for at least two minutes
here i can see 28.6
watch it for six minutes plus so that's
the audience retention it gives us an
idea in terms of percentage how many
people or percentage of people watch the
video at what length so that's audience
retention so we want to keep that number
high at the very initial stage of the
video and we want to keep it high
throughout and that's why you always
want to create high quality content
using those examples using imagery
making it organized content
not pausing you know going from one
point to the other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or youtube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by autoplaying the next
video so if you enable this feature it's
going to go from one video to another
pattern interrupts keep the audience
engaged so
basically
it allows your audience to stay within
one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaging to the audience so
what do we mean by that well if i go
back again to my audience retention
report how engaging was it well i could
see 42 percent 43
watched it on average of 3 minutes and
21 seconds so to me that's pretty good
of course we always want percent of the
video
the video is seven minutes long if
almost half of our audience saw over
half of the video then i would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video and
if your video is not engaging you know
you can always go back and edit it or
fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location okay we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into youtube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if i click on
more i can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video was
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page i could see the traffic
sources i could see the gender and age
so if i click on the viewer age report i
can see the percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it uh where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within youtube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at youtube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically
we can't rank without engagement our
videos won't rank unless we have
engagement so that's why it's important
so engagement is somebody liking the
video commenting sharing it or
subscribing each one of these is
important to ranking so yes you need to
line keywords yes you need to have high
quality content so when you do both of
those and you upload your video then
it's up to the viewer and so
the hard work that you put out for the
video is hopefully going to pay
dividends with engagement so you want
people to do one of these four okay so
let's talk about
what that means so how do i get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to word stream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged is keeping it entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember on the high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that'll
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help in ranking your video higher so
just as i mentioned in the last segment
about
youtube analytics and all the different
reports available on youtube hey if you
have questions on those just go ahead
and add a comment so that's a way to
entice your users or your viewers to add
comments is if they have questions
because you know with videos you're not
going to be able to cover every detail
or every minute detail about a
particular topic you can only cover in
some cases the topic at a high level so
users are going to have comments or
questions naturally and so the comments
section is a good way to remind viewers
hey if you have a question or comment go
ahead and put in the comment section
because that will lend to engagement as
well so we want to add sources from high
quality websites that'll help with
engagement okay use humor in your video
we want to be able to
basically you know make it human-based
we don't want to be robots so we want to
be able to sound like you know we know
we're talking about but at the same time
talk to the viewer not necessarily at
the viewer or
looking the other way and just going
through the motions so adding humor
adding personality never hurts at the
end of the day we are all human adding
that clear call to action at the end of
the video will also
lead to engagement so if we win the
video with hey leave your comments on
this video or hey feel free to share
this video with colleagues who are
interested then that's a call to action
that's likely going to lead to more
engagement reply to your comments as
well so if you have comments we always
want to reply to them likely those
comments are going to be questions
because again as i mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on youtube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you're going
to start feeling really good and what is
that going to do look at that feel good
it's going to lead to confidence which
in turn is going to probably lead to
more videos and that's exactly what we
do at simply learn we're in the
education business but we're in it to
not only educate but making sure that
our videos are shown to as many people
as possible so that we can educate as
many people as possible so it's all it's
contagious so getting ranked feels good
and then once you get ranked then you
know you probably have good engagement
okay let's talk about how to promote
your content so once you've done all the
hard work getting your video done high
quality content optimize with keywords
and then publish to youtube we want to
let everybody in the world know about it
right so we want to promote it we've
done all the work we want to promote it
now so is it necessary to promote it i
would say yes because once your video is
published you want to reach out you want
to reach out to your audience not
necessarily on youtube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
facebook or twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms i am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on facebook yeah go
ahead and post some you're active on
twitter go ahead and tweet something it
could be you know on linkedin group if
you're part of a linkedin group about
you know machine learning then go ahead
and post something to that group to
promote the video so that's going to
help drive traffic to the video and then
help with engagement so we want to
engage with our audience on those social
media sites it really depends on what
you're active on so if you have a large
following on twitter then go ahead and
you know share that youtube video link
on twitter with the tweet that's going
to drive traffic from twitter to youtube
remember you know you're going to be
able to see audience engagement or
retention by getting people to watch the
video so you're going to be able to see
right away by promoting the video and
driving traffic to the video how
engaging it is remember the more people
you have watch the video the more
engaging it becomes the better it's
going to rain so it's an ecosystem and
promoting your content is part of that
ecosystem so it all starts with social
media if you're active on whatever
platform that is go ahead and promote it
so you can also look at you know
content-based social media sites or
social media content based platforms
like reddit or flickr for example so you
can participate in a forum discussion on
reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content-based sites
that are q a uh related like cora for
example core is a really good site where
you know if you go there post
information about machine learning or
the basics of machine learning with the
link back to the video it's gonna help
because not only is it going to drive
traffic but it's going to signal to
google hey
a lot of traffic coming from quora this
is going to bode well for this video in
terms of ranking so here's an example
you know if you find a question that you
can post on core then you're going to
get people to click on your video and
respond accordingly on quora or you can
act as the person responding to a
question that's already there so
somebody already asked a question about
what is machine learning you can respond
with your video has the answer so you
can just simply embed your video url as
part of your answer that'll help drive
traffic so you can also create your own
blog and embed your videos so in the
case of machine learning here we have an
example machine learning what is it and
why it matters so this goes nicely with
the video so here you could see the
person the author of this blog went
ahead and embedded the relevant video in
the blog post so they play off one
another nicely you can also opt in for
influencer marking meaning hey you can
reach out to somebody in this example
here you know katie nuggets posted
information about machine learning so in
this case why choose machine learning as
a career well they got information and
then what did they do they went ahead
and embedded the video about machine
learning basics and so working with you
know influencers in a particular
category or topic will help drive
traffic to the video you can also create
a youtube playlist so playlists tend to
rank high in youtube searches so if you
find yourself doing a lot of videos well
go ahead and you know go to your channel
and simply on your channel you can go
ahead and create playlists so when you
create playlists basically what you're
doing is you're organizing the content
into different playlists no different
than say the music you have set up on
your you know your iphone or ipad or or
ipod whatever it is you're using so
you're just creating different videos in
a particular category and it youtube
likes it it's organized it's going to
help you get your videos found quicker
and easier on youtube itself by putting
your videos in a playlist so here you
could see we have entire playlist on
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing big data digital
marketing project management's a lot of
different playlists very organized if
somebody goes to the channel they're
going to be able to go to the playlist
that's interesting to them and see all
the videos there so it allows not only
the end user to find what they're
looking for but it's good for youtube
because youtube likes those playlists so
we want to engage our audience by
posting your video link on a community
page so you can do that within youtube
and you can prefer to link your youtube
channel in your email so you can also do
that so for example if i go back to
youtube and i'm looking at a youtube
video you know i can always click share
so here i'm gonna get a particular url
that's associated with the video and i
can just embed that so i can embed the
whole thing in my email i can embed it
on a web page or a blog post so just by
clicking share i can also immediately
share it onto the social media platforms
that we mentioned facebook linkedin
reddit okay tumblr so there's a lot of
ways to
embed the video not just that on blog
posts or influencer blog posts but in
our email and on social media as well so
here's an example of what we can do with
a youtube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark that content so that
people can find it and you can always
opt for backlinks so that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on youtube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on youtube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid iq or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose lsi keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds are the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titles
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number
or a question like what is machine
learning so we want to use relevant meta
tags for the videos and we want to use
popular youtube tags so we want to be
able to tag our videos appropriately to
watch the length of your meta tags so
there are links involved remember
keywords at the beginning of the title
target keywords in the title description
and tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when i say thumbnails i mean the
actual title tag itself or the meta
description we want to use high-res
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your youtube video ranked and today
we're going to talk about how to
increase youtube subscribers so with
youtube it's all about subscribers the
number of subscribers you have on
youtube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your youtube videos so
it's all about how to get subscribers
and today we're going to talk about how
to get more subscribers and before we
begin let's just show you what we did at
simply learn so if we look at the past
365 days on our youtube channel you can
see we started here back in uh if we
look back at march 9 2018 we had 208 and
you could see just over the course of
the year it kept creeping up creeping up
creeping up and creeping up we've gained
you know a significant number of
subscribers over the last year and
what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it is about posting videos
because when you post videos you have
people who can watch those videos when
you have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
will see it so it's kind of a halo
effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase those subscriptions so
let's start out with some of those tips
we're going to start with creating
engagement informative content so
engaging in informative content that's
where we're going to start talking today
about how to increase subscriptions then
we're going to talk about publishing
videos frequently so simply learn you
can see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks so another tip we're going to
talk about is how to optimize your
youtube videos so there's a lot that
goes into optimization but this is a key
key tip to pay attention to because when
it comes to posting publishing videos on
youtube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
youtube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos in
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel we have to create highly
engaging and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you got to create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audio okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for i mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on youtube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on youtube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't veer off
course if you veer off course you're not
going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what i normally do is
you know have an outline and then once i
have the outline then i go ahead and
create my slides if i will or my topics
points i want to talk about and then i
write out those points i want to make
sure i get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of this session i showed you
an example of simply learned subscribers
over the past 365 days and so that's
what we want to do we want to be clear
but use examples to punctuate the
content or the point we're trying to get
across so we want to include sources
from high quality sites so if you're
going to use examples make sure they're
from relevant high quality sites and
when i mean high quality meaning does
your audience know who that source is or
that site if it's really specific and
your audience may not know then it's
probably not high quality so just keep
that in mind always play to your
audience so you want to start your video
with an interesting hook so again i go
back to this example if you're still
watching this then the hook worked we
showed you our subscriptions we showed
you how we grew over the course of a
year you could see our growth and part
of it was posting a lot of videos with
relevant and informative content and so
you see how we did it so you're paying
attention you want to know how to do it
and so part of what we did is exactly
what i'm telling you now we know who our
audience is we plan out our scripts we
use good examples and we start our
videos with interesting hooks now when
we do our videos we also create original
content so that goes back to planning
your script okay you always want to you
know come across as original and
informative when you do that you're
going to be engaging but if you're
leveraging somebody else's content then
the engaging part may not resonate
because it's not your content to begin
with so always always always use
original content okay so keep the
content flow organized so again that
goes back to an outline you know feel
free to change up the outline so the
flow makes sense add visuals to your
content and make it appealing always
include images to me if you can use
images in your videos and play off the
video or the images then it's just gonna
flow and make it a little bit more
engaging and appealing meaning the
content so visuals help guide and aid in
the points you're trying to make so
don't make it so text heavy you know
accentuate it balance it with some
images use simple language and crisp
sentences meaning don't choose jargon
don't come across and talk above your
audience you always want to talk to your
audience and talk in a language that
they're going to understand so it goes
back to point one if you know who your
audience is you're talking to them as if
they're right in front of you and not
you're above them or they're below you
you want to talk at them so add cards
end screens and pattern interrupts to
engage your audience and so youtube
cards are just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that youtube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
youtube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not gonna subscribe
to your channel so think about youtube
videos as a popular tv program that
comes on once a week when a new episode
comes on based on the regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps your users stay engaged so
for example if i go back to our youtube
channel you know what helped us gain
subscribers was our consistency in
publishing videos you could see we were
consistent publishing a couple of videos
a week every couple of weeks and so this
helps users stay engaged they know when
the video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or youtube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so i subscribe to
simplylearn's channel i subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime google analytics
publishes a video i get an email that
says hey google analytics youtube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is i'm checking my email and
i'm getting this notification in gmail
so guess what i can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email i don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner youtube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging i always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the youtube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
then you'll find that the more you ramp
it up the more subscribers you're gonna
get so tip three optimize your youtube
videos so optimizing your videos will
help your content rank higher on youtube
so this is a give must it's not a given
it's a must you must optimize your
videos if you want people to see them of
course if you don't optimize people
aren't going to see them then people
aren't going to engage and then not
subscribe so it's just kind of a
snowball effect so this is an important
tip so i mentioned it at the beginning
when we were going over all the items
we're going to discuss this is the one
item that is a must and a given to some
degree because if you don't optimize
your videos they're just not going to be
found so you need that audience to watch
your video so audiences who tend to
interact more with your content have
more chance to subscribe to your channel
but they're not going to subscribe if
they don't even watch your video so
there is a snowball effect in play here
if we don't optimize your videos so okay
rob what are some of the tips to
optimize your youtube video well let's
go through some of those tips so to
ensure your videos reaches the relevant
audience on youtube you need to optimize
the title description in the video tag
okay rob what do you mean by title
description and video tag so let's take
a look at that so when you actually
create your youtube video you're going
to have an opportunity to put in a title
you're going to have an opportunity to
put in a description and you're going to
have an opportunity to add text so those
are the three key areas okay so once you
put in that what it looks like on the
front end is this so if i go back to
youtube and here you can see another
video that we did about a month ago you
could see what is seo so if that's our
topic that's our title uh or of the
content of the video then the title of
the video is going to be what is seo and
you can see we also added in some other
content for the title so what is seo and
how does it work seo tutorial for
beginners and then our brand name so we
have some content to work with for the
title okay and then the description we
have a lot of characters to work with
description so use as much as you can
here to describe what the video is about
here you can see we did that and so it's
always good to include this information
okay and then you can see we have tags
up here seo seo tutorial for beginners
digital marketing so we put in the
necessary information here on this video
to help us rank because if we don't
optimize it we're not going to rank and
so you can see we just put a lot of
relevant content around the description
around the title and around those tags
by doing so we're able to optimize this
video and get found so that's just an
example three of the things you can do
to help optimize your youtube video so
if you want to watch more on how to
optimize meta tags then i suggest maybe
watching the other video we did on the
subject how to rank youtube videos so
this goes into more detail about how to
optimize the title the meta description
and the meta tags but those are three
quick fields or areas that you can use
to optimize your video so just something
to keep in mind write a long description
with keywords time stamps and links so
what i mean by time stamps for time
stamp an audience can choose the section
of the video that they want to look for
and then links prefer to include
relevant links of your other videos so
those are just some additional tips to
help keep your content engaging so
remember when your content is engaging
then people are going to like it people
are going to share it and watch it later
so upload a captivating thumbnail okay
so you want to include a thumbnail
that's going to grab people's attention
you want to upload a transcript of the
video so that goes back to when you're
creating your content when you write
your original content you want to keep a
transcript of the content of the video
so that you can upload that as well and
then add a start screen and end screen
to your youtube videos so that way you
know it's somebody plays the video
they're gonna see it what it looks like
up front and then when we finish it
they're gonna see an end screen at the
end and so you just don't want to keep
it dark and black and non-descriptive so
according to backlinko using an exact
keyword in your video title can help you
with rankings so high ranking more views
more views more subscribers so that's
what i've been saying all along you need
to get these videos optimized so again
use an exact keyword in your video title
so let's go back again to that video i
just showed you a couple minutes ago
what is seo so here we started out with
a question what is seo that's the name
of the title that's one exact title of
the video that's our exact keyword okay
so what is seo and how does it work and
then seo tutorial for beginners so what
is seo is our exact keyword and that's
part of the video that's the content of
the video that's in the title and we use
it throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the rankings so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video included
in the title so backlinko also mentions
that there is a moderate correlation
between a channel's total subscribers
and rankings and so for some of you this
may be common sense it's just like
organic search if you're not ranking
you're not going to get traffic on
youtube if you're not ranking you're not
going to get eyeballs on your videos and
you're not going to get subscribers so
higher rankings can help you to get more
subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize
your youtube channel so we just talked
about optimizing our videos now we're
gonna turn our attention to our youtube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your views to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great youtube channel
trailer you also want to add channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good youtube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with the trailer
so you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're going to be posting and give them
a kind of a taste of what the future
videos are going to be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start out by
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're going to be posting one video a
month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking into your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description short interesting so in your
channel you want to have a description
of what the channel is all about what
kind of videos you're going to be
posting so in addition to the trailer
you want to write something short and
interesting then we want to use keywords
in our channel descriptions just like in
the videos with what is seo we included
what is seo in the title we included you
know what is seo in the description and
so we want to be true to what our
channel is so pick keywords not only
include those keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters of your channel description
because that's what's shown next your
channel on the search results so for
example here you can see
we have a description here simply learn
is one of the world's leading
certification training providers we
partner with companies and individuals
to address and so you could see those
characters
100-150 or what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's trying to
understand hey simply learn just
uploaded this video who is simply learn
so you want to write short interesting
channel description so that when
somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your brand's
all about so and your description with
an appropriate call to action so short
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call to action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention to the simply
learn channel page and here you can see
we recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the 200 000k subscribers so two
hundred thousand subscribers is a big
achievement for simply learn we went
ahead and updated our channel art and
i'm sure we will reach 500k we'll update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while so you have that option in youtube
to do i mean it's very simple so here
you can see simply learns channel we go
home get all our videos listed here we
got the about us you know something very
short interesting about us here's our
call to action for more information
visit simply learn so you want to make
sure when you create your channel get
some good artwork in there put your
description in play and create your
first videos and get them posted up
there and optimize them accordingly okay
so some other tips to go with that
channel art and description is a profile
picture relevant to your brand so you
always want to maybe put
the company logo up there okay so here
you can see we have the company logo at
accurate relevant channel keywords so if
we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with companies and
individuals so we're all about training
and training is one of our keywords so
you can see at simplylearn we provide
online training and machine learning aws
amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics so make sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
home page so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have ai
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing tutorials devop
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but i
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you
could take a video that maybe hasn't
gotten a lot of views or isn't ranked
particularly high maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if i go
back to our youtube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if i
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko youtube seo ranking factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with higher youtube search rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if i go back to our
channel if i go back about us make sure
your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to
get in the habit of producing high
quality videos because viewers don't
prefer to watch videos that have poor
audio and video quality it's just that
simple you need to know what it takes to
produce high quality videos if you don't
you're just going to discredit you're
not going to come across as relevant you
know i'm going to come across as
qualified professional there's a lot of
things attached to poor quality videos
so we need to
create high quality videos for the end
users so let's talk about some ways in
which you can create high quality videos
and so the first is to avoid any noise
in the background so you want to have a
nice quiet atmosphere no distractions so
people can hear you clearly and only you
clearly you want to use good audio
recording equipment there's plenty of
options available on the internet
usually i would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free it might not be
of good quality and you might not have
all the features and bells and whistles
with a free option so you know use good
audio recording equipment again it could
be online or it could be some software
just make sure that you're able to
produce good high quality video and
audio so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to have
something similar to an input volume
meter that way you can see whether your
audio is coming across or not so if
you're not seeing green lights then your
audio is not coming across if it's red
it might be distorted and so you want
something that's going to signify that
you're really pushing out good quality
audio you want to create your videos in
10 80 pixel size okay that's hd and so
you want to have at least minimum 1080.
so anything less than that it's probably
gonna come across as not so good maybe
staticky blurry
not professional not high def so you
want to create a high def video and 1080
is about the minimum you want to go and
then you want to plan your video script
before filming so it goes back to some
of the other points i made earlier you
always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professional so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video using slow motion and jump cuts
are some of the features you can use to
accentuate your points and then set up a
green background for recording again
this is for you know making sure that
the video part of it comes across in
good quality and stabilize your video
recordings with a tripod that way you're
not moving your video camera all around
and and again it's coming across as
shaky and poor quality shoot horizontal
videos you don't want to go vertical it
tends to cut the screen so you want to
stay horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video and you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature a good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software i can't
state this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
i would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing i just said it a
minute ago i'll say it again you want to
be able to have a really professional
video and high def when you have a good
professional video and high def with
good audio horizontal shots you know
nice green background image nice well
lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are gonna
take you seriously they're gonna see you
as a professional and then share or
subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're going to have to do it
all over again so follow these tips get
a high quality video and you should be
on your way to ranking in fact according
to backlinko youtube preferably ranks hd
videos so you got to have that 1080 uh
pixel size that way you know your video
is gonna come across crisp and clear and
youtube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in youtube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your youtube account it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in youtube so here creator
studio on the left side navigation i'm
just going to click channel then i'm
going to click branding and then once
you click branding you have the ability
to add your watermark and then you can
add it to the entire video at the end of
the video and specific start time and
then just click update and that's pretty
much it so you want to be able to add
this so that you can brand your videos
with an image and then add that cta so
this is a good good feature for youtube
it allows you to be consistent with all
your videos by branding and adding that
call to action tip seven engage with
your audience so you want to be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because the video and you
can't see people doesn't mean you can't
engage with them so when you interact
with your viewers especially when you
interact with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to going to
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of your busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with youtube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on youtube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback is always going to be positive
some of the feedback could be less than
positive or even negative there could be
mistakes so the idea behind getting
feedback is you want to look at it you
want to read it and you want to react to
it you want to react to it positively in
the form of you know what thank you for
the feedback and looking at the feedback
weighing it and incorporating the
feedback so you don't always want to
make the same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example and somebody looked at it and
gave us feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again so you always want
to learn from your mistakes and you want
to turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request the audience is giving us
feedback we should take that as positive
and sometimes that's creative sometimes
those ideas for more videos okay you
always want to ask questions to your
audience and reward excellent commenters
so we try to ask questions in our videos
and
when users respond with the answer if
there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give emoji hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience has taken the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a positive
so emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
youtube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
youtube has them other platforms like
facebook have them instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flesh so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
youtube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and get their
videos and use their videos and upload
them to your channel so according to
backlinko video comments have a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm going to ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
youtube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your youtube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how and you can use different
platforms so the first thing you want to
do is look at the platforms you're
already using if you're using facebook
and instagram that's probably a good
place to start but there's other
platforms you can also leverage and
we're going to talk about those so
social media most companies most
individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
facebook and instagram so you could
start there so with facebook you can
post something include the link of your
youtube video with facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video you can
also do the same on twitter or instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to youtube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimonial
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here test genix okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for aws so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your youtube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like gmail or yahoo or even hotmail or
outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your youtube channel it doesn't
have to be do a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your youtube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community page and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate with other youtube
channels this is always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on youtube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their channel
and you can take their video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you could join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so core there's always a
question of being posted and if you have
the answer to that question in the form
of your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
youtube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog post so if you're using a
platform like wordpress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post i like this option i think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you could promote other videos in
your end screen for example at the end
of your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like upon you know
collaborate with other people on youtube
you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video today
we're going to talk about how to get
traffic to your website so thank you for
joining and let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing
you're doing some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends and an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's gonna happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing and
designing the website to make it look
good but you didn't do anything
or any planning or any strategy around
bringing users to your website so the
two go hand in hand you just can't build
a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or
you can increase brand awareness or
you can earn revenue through sponsored
posts and advertisements so if you have
for example a lot of content on your
website you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're gonna earn a percentage of that
click okay what that click is worth so
having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word ad
next to the domain so when somebody
clicks on that link simply learn is
going to pay google so that's how search
advertising works okay the next is
social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness a lot of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video so in this case you could see
cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad then it's going to be more
visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so that's paid advertising
again through search through social
through display but you can also promote
your site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms i mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or
e-commerce then you can also leverage
instagram which is part of facebook's
ecosystem so if you advertise on
facebook you can also advertise on
instagram and or instagram so it doesn't
have to be and facebook and instagram it
could be facebook or instagram you also
have linkedin as a platform linkedin is
great for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so linkedin is great if you're into
b2b focusing on the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site
by getting your product out there in the
form of a video and then you have
twitter twitter to me encompasses a lot
of different industries beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but a lot of people are
active on twitter and it's a great way
to generate some awareness and get some
clicks over to your website so these are
just some of the most popular social
media platforms of course there are
plenty more out there the third way in
which you can drive traffic to your site
is guest post blogging so
most of you already know what blogging's
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guest post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the right audience okay you
can expand your personal network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience
and then obviously for serves because it
generates a backlink so serps search
engine ranking pages means that hey if
you want to rank organically you're
going to have to generate some backlinks
so guest blogging is a way to generate
some backlinks to your site and an
effect that's going to help you get your
pages ranked higher because google is
going to recognize the relationship from
one blog to your blog and build up your
relevancy so some other benefits here to
guest blogging is you can grow your
social media following because you can
then promote that on social media that
you're guest blogging okay again you can
improve your online authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that guest blog
if it's a popular blog then it's not
going to help your domain and page
authority for seo and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to
thought leaders for interviews okay
could generate some credibility for you
and the other person so it's reciprocal
so it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other leaders in the
industry and the indirect net result of
that could be increased traffic because
if you do the interview and you record
it or if it's via video then you can
obviously post it on other platforms and
that could in turn drive traffic to your
website obviously just like guest
blogging it's going to increase your
reach so getting yourself out there if
nobody knows who your brand is and they
know who the thought leaders are and
they say you're interviewing the thought
leaders then that's going to put you in
front of these people and so it's going
to increase your reach another way to
drive traffic to your website is just to
make sure your website's responsive and
what do we mean by response of well we
mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
contents all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion uh to use specifically just
for them that they can use on your
website or talk directly to them because
you know that they're followers they're
repeat customers they purchase for you
multiple times so talk to them
differently as well you know who these
people are and that's what building a
brand's all about it's about identifying
your brand with other people okay and
then identify people who identify with
your brand and messaging and talking to
them as if they're part of your own
community your own family so you can use
user generated content that provides
future marketing strategies so the
feedback you get from your own community
could be in turn used to promote or used
in future marketing strategies i.e
advertising i.e
post on social okay it can also provide
pr opportunities so it's a chance for
you to you know put out press releases
based on the community that you built so
any brand regardless of who it is should
be able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the
what they deserve the respect and
loyalty that they deserve as well
because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to drive traffic
is be active in the comments section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessarily have to be
another blog per se it could be other
sites like reddit or quora or media
sites that have a lot of content that
are broken out by industry that allow
you to engage in conversation allow you
to either upvote or share or respond
okay so be active because when you're
active people are going to see that hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or organic search so in order to
drive traffic to your site you're going
to have to implement an seo strategy why
do you want to implement an seo strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still king in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement an
engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a document
or the clicking on the play button of a
video or or submitting a form or signing
up for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of engagement so the the
amount of traffic you drive from organic
search to your website is only going to
improve engagement okay so
you can also provide and improve user
experience and what do we mean by that
well if you're getting lots of traffic
from organic search you have a really
good opportunity to do a b testing and
when you do a b testing you can improve
user experience meaning you're showing
one variation against the other from
people coming from organic search and so
this is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in new women's red nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're going to
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of
product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with seo we want to be able to
build backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on-page
and off page and so
off-page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just links that direct
users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
back linking because it's an off-page
strategy why is it an off-page seo
strategy because if google crawls that
other site that has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore
we're going to trust this site so
by google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being improved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're gonna follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get indexed the quicker you get found
and then it helps with referral traffic
so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and
the opposite of backlinks are internal
links so
you want to do internal linking and that
just means connecting one page on your
site to another and why is that
beneficial because it can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise find via your
navigation so if you're active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links you want to move people
through your site you want the flow of
traffic to go from one page to another
to another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website google is going to follow those
links and index those pages and google
does give credit from an seo perspective
from an internal linking perspective so
if one page is linked to another and
that page has really good relevance in
the eyes of google then the other page
is probably going to benefit from that
the other reason we want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply the rate at which people land on
a page and then leave so if i have 100
people land on my home homepage and only
one person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by page rank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and we'll meet me by link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is long tail keywords and long
tail keywords to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so
they're usually three or longer keywords
in a phrase okay so long tail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red
nike running shoes 2019
or some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are
less competition so if you're using
broad keywords like red shoes then who
doesn't want to be found for red shoes
well you don't necessarily you don't
want to be found for red shoes because
it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's gonna have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chance of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like i just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for seo so remember seo is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on-page
is all about making sure those keywords
you choose are integrated in with the
page you want to be found for and so if
you're using a long tail keyword it's
just easy to work that keyword in so it
enables easier on-page optimization okay
let's switch away from seo to email
marketing so let's focus on email
marketing as a form or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email you're writing a
specific message to that person well
email marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your
email's targeted if it's targeted it can
be cost effective why because sending
large amounts of emails or let's just
say an email to a large amount of people
or a large group of people is going to
be cost effective it's not cost per
click you know it's not cost per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so it just really depends
on how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely majority of the people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens an email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increased
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you could put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics okay if you use google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for effective
social media promotion it's a great way
to bring traffic to your website so
why do we recommend webinars well
because it provides direct content
contact within your target group what do
we mean by contact with your target
group well you're going to host a
webinar and you're going to invite this
targeted group of people who are
interested in your product or service so
if you have a facebook community you
could do a facebook live event or you
could do a youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're gonna
be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's gonna
help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so having a
webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embed it in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience so even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get built
trust it's going to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery videos really do engage
with the audience and so the more video
you can do the better off you are
because again you can leverage social to
draw attention to your brand and product
and service and then you can have that
video on your website to increase
engagement which in turn increases
conversions and sales and improves roi
so always think video there's plenty of
video software out there that you can
leverage and the great thing about video
2 is hey most people are using mobile
phones these days smartphones and so
video works just as well on mobile as it
does on desktop so keep that in mind you
know video is going to be engaging
regardless of what device somebody uses
and then of course if they're watching
the video on facebook or youtube then
chances are they're going to
share
that particular video which is going to
bode well for your brand and traffic
okay so video if somebody likes a video
it's very easy to share video especially
from a mobile phone so youtube just
makes it so easy to share or like or
subscribe to a channel it just it
becomes that much easier things can go
viral and chances them going viral video
are going to be greater okay so other
ways to drive traffic to your website is
submit your content to content
aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like reddit that provides a great
platform for you to post your content so
that's what a content aggregator is
really a site like reddit or medium or
quora where you could post content to a
large number of people okay so with
reddit people are either going to upvote
it or downvote it so the more upvotes
you get or thumbs up or likes or people
who encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case right across
the board whether it's a a social post
or blog post make sure the content's
unique professional and interesting and
then if you do say put something on
medium or you do put something on quora
and it is professional and interesting
and thought-provoking then people are
going to react to it and then that again
could lead to traffic but even if it
doesn't lead to traffic it helps build
brand awareness so if you have content
just like videos leverage it put the
content out there and when you put
content out there it's only gonna
especially if it's good content but it's
gonna put you in a good light so don't
be afraid to share your content on the
likes of reddit or medium or core or
some of these other content aggregator
websites because good things are only
going to happen and again referral
traffic seo brand awareness conversions
so all these are inherent benefits of
just sharing your content okay and then
finally we want to learn from analytics
okay so what do we mean learning from
analytics so there are plenty of
analytics platforms out there one of the
most popular is google analytics so you
want to make sure you're tracking
traffic on your site with google
analytics so i have to do is just go to
google analytics via search sign up add
the analytics code to your website and
voila they're doing all the heavy
lifting they're going to track traffic
coming to your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that i sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from youtube based on that
video i posted or they coming from
reddit based on the content i just
posted there or are they coming from
organic search
so google analytics can help us
understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search so to help
us measure our seo efforts and then with
google analytics you could segment so we
could segment by mobile we can segment
by desktop returning user new user by
campaign by page by language by city by
region i mean there's so many ways in
which to segment your audience and
segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search that's a
segment and you can look at that
information and analytics if that's your
target audience then you can see how
they're performing okay so anal there
are a lot of benefits to google
analytics definitely want to take
advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data
is you want to be able to fine-tune your
website so take advantage of the data
that google analytics or any other
analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately today we're
going to talk about seo tools let's get
started so if you're doing seo and
you're doing on-page and off-page seo
for an organization or website you're
going to need some tools to help you so
you can't go at it alone you can't do
anything manually you have to lean on
tools to help you work more efficiently
help you gain an advantage and so if
you're doing seo you're going to need
tools for keyword research you're going
to need tools to help you with the
technical aspects related to seo you're
going to have to use some tools for
off-page seo including backlink
monitoring and analysis and then there's
tools for helping you track where your
keywords and pages rank so there's tools
for every element of seo and today we're
going to take a look at some of the best
tools out there on the market to help
you do your job better so let's start
with the keyword research so with
keyword research tools you can do your
job a lot more efficiently finding the
right relevant keywords i mean that's
really key to seo is finding keywords
that are relevant to your business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from certain tools
you also want to get forecasts for
certain targeted keywords you want to be
able to generate a list of latent
semantic index and type keywords or
keywords close to the keyword you're
trying to target you want to be able to
select primary and secondary keywords
wisely so having a list of keywords or
certain data points will help you do
that and you want to be able to identify
the keywords that your competitors are
also ranking for so good keyword
research tool will help you do all of
those things so what are some of the
tools out there well look no further
than some of the free ones that google
offers like google trends so google
trends is a good tool that you can lean
on if so if we look at google trends all
you need to do is trends.google.com
you could type in a keyword i can look
at the volume or interest of that
keyword over time here i'm looking at
football versus american football and i
could see how it's trending then i could
see you know how it trends in specific
regions of say the united states as my
market i can also look at other related
queries similar to
football or american football and so
google trends is a good tool helps you
look at the volume helps you look at
what specific regions help you look at
other keywords you know if you want you
can simply just do a keyword search or
you can actually just see what's
trending just by looking at the latest
stories and insights so we could see
international women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
google trends now you could also use
another google tool called google
keyword planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a google ads
account so if we go into google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need a keyword planner but when you're
in keyword planner you can find new
keywords so if i type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that i need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average monthly volume and the great
thing here is i can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing i could see what the
trend is over time i could see what the
competition is i could see you know if
i'm going to bid on this keyword i could
see what the bidding range is so more
important i could see the volume and i
can see the competition here's my volume
for this keyword over the last 12 months
on average and here's my competition so
google's keyword planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for relevant keywords like
semrush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool i use that's not listed here is moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information i
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz is freemium some are paid some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these are the ones i would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical seo so
for technical seo you're going to need
to use some tools there's no getting
around that because you want to be able
to monitor how your website is
performing i mean is it loading slow for
example does it have a lot of uh issues
with the website in terms of uh server
side rendering for example or server
response time what about four or fours
and redirects so you want to be able to
gather a lot of the technical
information that could aid or prohibit
your site from ranking so you want to be
able to also you know look at what the
bots are saying and how they're viewing
your website so if google goes to crawl
your site are they experiencing you know
a slow server response time where they
experiencing pages not found you also
want to see if you have a site map you
know what's the site map are these bots
crawling your site or getting the pages
from a site map again you want to be
able to lean on some of these tools to
help you fix errors that you may
encounter like meta tags or four or
fours or canonicals so you need a good
tool to help you manage all that and so
i'm going to go back to maz starting out
so if we go back to maz maz is a good
tool it's an all-in-one it's a great seo
platform so if i go to moz and i log
into an account i can just go to
sitecrawl and so what moz is going to do
it's going to give me a lot of
information about how moz's bot is
seeing my site okay so if i go to the
site crawl i can look at all the
particular critical uh issues that have
experienced so i could see four or four
errors okay reiterates related to that i
can see meta descriptions missing meta
descriptions duplicate content so
there's a lot of different issues that
moz is detecting for this particular
site and the great thing about moz and
this is why i use moz is my seo platform
i don't work for mods i've just used
them a long time is if you do have
issues then they give you ways to fix it
the how to fix it section so if i see
missing description here if i just click
on review and get a more in-depth
analysis as to what the issues are here
but i can also click on the why and how
to fix okay and they're going to give
you some information about how this is
impacting seo and what you could do to
fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues i have i have
you know 142 total metadata issues i
have 10 title tag two longs i have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example i just looked at metadata
issues you can see if i click on content
issues i have some duplicate content
that moz is recognizing or missing or
valid h tags so maz does a really really
great job laying on all the issues out
for you to recognize okay there's
another tool that i like to use called
screaming frog it's a pay tool so if we
go look here great thing i like about a
screaming frog it will crawl your site
and it will give you some list of issues
just like moz does of you know what it
sees in your site is it experiencing
four or fours broken links are there any
redirects it's picking up duplicate
content site maps you know they're
javascript issues how is it see the site
architecture so it really does take a
deep look at everything that could
impact your website from ranking okay
there are other tools out there like you
know deep crawl or woo rank they're both
paid and so pay tools are really great
as well it just depends on you know your
pricing structure what your budget is
but really when it comes to all these
tools they all more or less overlap and
do the same thing you just need to rely
on one of them to make sure that you're
able to see what the issues are now
there's nothing wrong with using two of
them just as a second reference point to
see if both are picking up the same
issue and of course i like to use search
console i always like to lean on google
search console because that is the
source so search console will also you
know give you some feedback on how
google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a sitemap so that's a
key to seo you want google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just uh signify to google where
your sitemap is located so the search
console does a lot more gives you some
html improvements gives you some
backlinking uh and then the process of
updating the search console user
interface so there's a new user
interface that you can use with google
search console the great thing is it's
free and it has everything you need to
know about your website and how it's
affected by seo organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it it has all the relevant information
you need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and analysis okay so this is
related to off-page seo so you're gonna
need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good or relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what this good links are and
what the bad links are pointing to your
website and you can also you know given
the tool also perform some competitor
analysis so you should be able to use a
tool to be able to compare how your
site's ranking against your competitor
okay you want to measure the ratio
referring domains to backlinks so how
many pure domains are linking to your
site so you want a tool that's going to
be able to tell you that you want to
identify and disavow poor backlinks okay
so you want to be able to recognize
which sites are linking to yours that's
actually hurting you from an seo
standpoint and you want to be able to do
something about that okay you want to
measure citation flow and trust flow you
want to check the ratio of link
distribution in terms of is it internal
or external or you know what kind of
sites are linking to my site are they
you know social related are they pure
content related and then you want to be
able to track the number of do follow
and no follow links you know how many
links pointing to our site are actually
telling google and other bots not to
follow the link or how many are actually
allowing the bots to follow that link if
a bot follows a link it's going to pass
what we call link juice so you're going
to get credit for the backlink if it's a
no follow you're not going to get credit
for the backlink and we want to be able
to measure that and so we want to have
tools that will help us do that so what
are some of those tools well hrefs is a
good tool it's a pain tool majestic is a
freemium tool moz again moz is the tool
i use scm rush and then again i gotta
mention google search console so let's
take a look at some of these tools in
terms of backlink monitoring and
analysis so let's start with google
search console again it's free you just
have to verify your site and so if i go
to google search console i can look at
links and i can see what external links
i have pointing to my site okay so i
could see i have seventeen thousand in
this example pointing to the homepage of
this particular site okay so if i click
on that i can see all the the top sites
pointing to
my home page now from an off page seo
perspective do you want every backlink
or external link pointing to your
homepage no so you want links pointing
to internal pages so you want to be able
to measure that so i can see what the
top linking sites are and i can also see
what the anchor text is so do i want my
anchor text always to be my brand name
no i want it to be you know keyword
we're trying to target search console
also gives you some internal links okay
one of the top link pages for internal
links so from an seo perspective you
always want to have a nice balance of
internal linking so this report helps
you understand what pages are getting
links and are the links evenly spread so
this is google search console this is
the links report this is totally free
this is provided by google all you have
to do is verify your site now if we go
over to moz we type in a domain any
domain so i just typed in simply learn
okay moz has some metrics that are
important to off page seo including
domain authority so the higher your
domain authority the better off you are
and so what helps a domain authority
grow is how many quality links are
pointing to that domain and so here we
could see over 7500
linking domains to simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointing okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain authority has been
over time they're going to tell me the
top followed links to this site so they
can tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority of those sites okay here
i can get a nice graphical breakdown of
the linking domains by domain authority
so you want pages with high domain
authority pointing to your site so here
i could see 69 linking domains between
91 and 100 so that's really good we want
high relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console i can
see the top anchor text being used okay
and i can see the top pages that have
you know good page authority on the site
i could see following versus nofollow on
internal and external links so this is
just the overview so moz really really
does break down for you you know what
those pages and linking domains are so
if i just click on linking domains now i
could get a detailed look for my home
page what domains are pointing to our
domain so i can see microsoft.com has a
domain authority of 100. youtube 99 and
so not only does moz provide you with
the domains it also provides you with
their domain authority score and spam
score so you want to keep an eye on any
particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain authority will
hurt your domain and page authority for
that page so moz does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if i take a look look at
another example here majestic so
majestic again i can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then i'm going to just revert
back to moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page seo you know moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis i can compare my domain
authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external follow
links or external no follow links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that i
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing
off-page seo you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor texts are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors i mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
seo so you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we assign primary and secondary
keywords to pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page seo we're doing all
this work for seo okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page seo for the
keywords we covet and the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure our click-through rates and
impressions we want to be able to track
the ranking for both desktop and mobile
for specific locations and we want to
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords so in other words we
want to look at trends is it keyword
ranking is it going up and ranking is it
going down in rank and if it's going
down in ranking then you need to take
action so you need a tool a good tool
for rank tracking so we can look no
further than again google search console
it's free it's right from the source so
let's take a look at what google search
console has to offer in terms of rank
tracking so if i go to google search
console and i put in a url what it's
going to do is it's going to give me and
this is the search queries report it's
going to give me what queries people
have used to actually type into
google.com and it's going to be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page that's an
impression and if i did receive an
impression meaning did my page show up
in the organic listing then did i get a
click as a result and so in this case if
i got 68 impressions and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a 14.7
percent click-through rate and so what
search console will also do is say hey
look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device so i could see you know mobile
i've had
899 impressions over the last three
months on mobile and i received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile was 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keyword somebody's using on google
search as a query and how many
impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the rate
and then average position so in theory
the higher you are positioned on google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if i'm not positioned properly for
keyword let's say say page 2 then i'm
probably not going to receive as many
clicks as i would like so that's search
console there are other tools out there
like hrefs again does a good job of
tracking amz tracker we look at winter
so there's some good tools out there i'm
just going to show you another one again
i'm going to go back to moz for example
so moz has a tool called so if i go back
into the account so moz has a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimize
pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
moz and so moz allows you to do that and
so
what moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
rank between positions 1 and 3 11
through 20 4 through 10 21 through 50.
so we'll be able to see where our
keywords rank and so it gives you a
breakdown here of nationally in the
united states where this keyword is
ranked and if it's moved up or down and
for what url is it ranked for and so you
can label so the keywords and and this
is what you want to look for in a good
tool you want to be able to organize
your keywords and label them so for all
our branded keywords we want to be able
to label them branded because ideally
you don't want to optimize for your
brand keywords so maybe we want to
exclude our brand keywords and look at
our non-brand keywords in terms of
ranking and so you can certainly add
locations and look at specific locations
the whole idea between a good ranking
tool is to be able to measure you know
if a keyword is trending up or down okay
so i can simply look at a particular
keyword and i can see the trend of that
keyword and then you know if a keyword
is not ranking then we want to wonder
why it's not ranking well is it
difficult is it not ranking because of
its difficulty or can we do a better job
of optimizing for that keyword and so
moz also has a page optimization tool so
if you're not ranking for keyword you
can flip over the page optimization tool
then put in the keyword put in the url
and moz will give you some idea as to
what you can further do to optimize the
page okay so that's moz you know this is
ahrefs so you can see ahrefs does the
same thing they provide you some
visibility average position how much
traffic you know where you're ranking in
terms of positions one through three
four through ten eleven through fifty
and so you wanna be able to get a sense
of where my track keywords are trending
are they training up are they trending
down and the whole idea again beyond a
ranking tools if you're trending down
you to be able to
address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page seo can we do
a better job of optimizing or off page
does that page need more backlinks so
that's why you need a backlink tool to
support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you can
take advantage of now there are also a
few important seo tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid iq
so let's take a look at vid iq so if i
load in say video in youtube in this
example how to rank youtube videos i
have a vid iq extension loaded into my
browser in chrome and so now i can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
reddit but further i can look at how the
video was optimized so they're telling
me the title's too long here maybe
shorten it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on facebook it
hasn't been shared on twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
youtube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your youtube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid iq
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know youtube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for content
optimization there are tools you can use
like seo site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
moz as an example just going back to moz
as you already know i use mozawa so they
have a page optimization so you could
check the content how your optimize your
content so it's going to give me some
good feedback on you know is your page
title meta description are they in line
okay so it's going to give you some good
feedback on that you also have again i
have to allude to search console you can
always look at a particular page and
search console see if it has any errors
as well so is it duplicated meta
description is it duplicated title tag
is it any pages missing title tags your
meta descriptions so when it comes to
content you can look at search console
you can lean on moz or you can lean on
some of these other paid versions like
site analyzer when it comes to traffic
and metrics look no further than google
analytics there is a free version of
google analytics as well as a paid
version so if i go into google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals i set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at first in google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if i go to google analytics
if i go to acquisition all traffic
channels i should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so i could see how
many users how many sessions then if i
click on landing pages i could see what
landing page they went to today we're
going to talk about seo tips and tricks
so let's get started and throughout this
series we're gonna have a few tips to
share with you and we'll start out with
tip number one opt for smarter ways to
do keyword research
and so
if you listen to any of our seo
tutorials in the past you know that
keyword research is the first step but
the most crucial step in starting seo so
when we do keyword research we want to
be able to
basically find keywords that we feel are
relevant to our business that we want to
be found on search for and so here are a
few tips that can help you do that
research in a more efficient manner the
first thing we want to do is identify a
list of keywords that are relevant so we
only want to focus on relevant keywords
for a business that's a given so what i
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of those
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example
if we have a company that sells dried
figs in a spreadsheet as an example if i
show you a spreadsheet maybe we want to
focus in on just dried fig and maybe we
want to focus on dried fig recipes so go
ahead and put those in a column you know
some of these keywords that you know you
want to be found for so that's really
the first step they need to be relevant
so put them in a spreadsheet so that you
can build keywords around that list then
we want to choose keywords and when we
choose keywords we want to have some
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what i mean by volume
i mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the key
word of product fit meaning you know is
the keyword relevant you always want to
stay true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example christmas tree you're only
going gonna have a spike you know during
the winter or excuse me the october
november december months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume
relevancy always trumps uh volume or any
other metric commercial intent so we
want to
look at keywords that for example have
buy in them they may have low search
volume but if somebody's typing in that
keyword then we can insinuate that the
consumer who typed in that keyword is
ready to make the purchase so we want to
look at what the intent is of that
keyword and then again the difficulty
always up for keywords that have low
difficulty or competition and so in
order to get these metrics we can use
third party tools and i'm going to show
you a couple of examples of third-party
tools you can use that will give you
some of this information so the first
tool i'm going to show you is google ads
keyword planner so if i'm have a google
ads account i could simply go to tools
and then choose the keyword planner and
from there i want to find new keywords
so if i choose the keyword dried figs
because that's the keyword i put in my
spreadsheet that i'm interested in
optimizing for and then maybe drive fake
recipes that was the other keyword theme
so if i enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here i can see dried
figs i have an average monthly search
volume 8 100. that means on average over
the last 12 months that's how many
people have typed in that keyword here i
can see a little bit of a trend i just
hover my mouse over that graph i can see
again for seasonality impact if there is
any seasonality what the volume is on
average per month then i could see the
competition is high and because this is
google ads because it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what i should be bidding on that
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once i get this
information here i can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that google ads gives
us a high or low now if we're trying to
measure
ratio between
volume and competition we want to get an
actual sense of what that competition is
so what i always do as a best practice
is go into google search if i go to
google search and i type in dried figs
i'm going to see the actual volume is 34
million 500 000. so i could see that's
the actual search volume for this
particular keyword however if i add a
syntax called all in title before that
keyword with a colon space and then hit
enter then i could see the actual
volume reduces to 31 000. and basically
what this tells me is that 31 000
listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag so if a web
page has dried fig our targeted keyword
in the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if i go into our keyword
analysis here and i
go ahead and enter in that information
so what's my keyword my keyword is dried
figs
okay my volume was 8 100 my competition
was 31 000 and so that gives me a ratio
of 81 divided by 31 000 if i make that
into a percentage basically 26
so that's my keyword effectiveness index
or kei or ratio between volume and
competition and so that's an a way that
you can
gather information is by using google
ads enter the information into a
spreadsheet and then sort all your data
by kei you could sort it by volume you
could sort it by competition all these
metrics matter alternatively as another
tool you can use moz so moz has a
keyword explore tool okay so if i type
in the keyword dried figs focusing on
the united states i could see that moz
says hey look there's anywhere between 4
300 and 6 500 in terms of volume out of
100 the difficulty is 41. and so i can
expect a click-through rate of you know
and so basically the great thing about
moz's keyword explorer tool is i can
also look at the serp analysis search
engine results pages what serp stands
for and i can analyze the serp for a
particular keyword in moz so i want to
be able to understand what my
competition is doing so here i can see
if i really want to try and optimize for
that keyword i could see what the other
pages are ranked for that keyword in the
on page one i can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here i could see that we have
a number of different sites listed here
so if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to
climb over to be number one on google so
i find that the keyword explore tool in
moz is very helpful for understanding
your competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant i
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify trends
from a site search query like amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into moz and
we can see just by typing in some of the
keywords we're focusing on we can see if
our competitors are ranking for the same
keywords just by using that keyword
explorer tool and then another thing we
want to look at is lsi or latent
semantic indexing so that's a fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of the
page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we can also stay up to
date on industry news as we'll help you
learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt to
subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here i'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if i simply just go to search engine
watch dot com i find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
can see
why seo and front-end developers are the
perfect search marketing team another
article about optimizing your channel
youtube channel five easy steps so
there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to seo
and keyword research we could also look
at other third party sites like
wikipedia reddit and core for example so
if i go to quora i can do a search for
dried figs and i could see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas to build
a keyword a list around so for example
the health benefits of dried figs okay
our dry figs safe for diabetes best ways
to eat dry figs so those are all good
keyword themes that we could build a
keyword list around and i did that
simply just by typing in dried figs on
core so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage when you're trying to build out
a keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so
it's all about content so we've already
done the keyword research we still need
to
kind of merge the two when we talk about
merging the two it's not just building
content around those keywords it's much
more than that when it comes to seo and
so that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so
first tip is we want to be able to
publish longer and engaging content
longer and engaging content tends to
rank higher in google why because you
have more content to work with and when
you have more content to work with you
can optimize it you can structure it you
can insert different assets like videos
and images and by keeping it long you're
gonna likely keep it engaging and so
google tends to lean in favor of content
that is well organized structured and
long because it is more likely to be
engaging for the end user we definitely
want to include those target keywords so
you want to be able to
you know insert those keywords into
those meta tag descriptions into those
title tags into those alt tags but you
want to work them in naturally you don't
want to force anything content should be
naturally written because if it's
naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use lsi keywords
in the content so lsi or
basically latent semantic indexing
basically just means different terms and
concepts related to your target keywords
so feel free to use terms that are
similar to what you're currently using
these keywords can definitely be used
for seo because they create more
visibility and potentially higher
rankings because it gives you an
opportunity to use keywords that are
natural and work for different
variations and let's look at examples so
if you're optimizing an e-commerce
category page and your keyword is one
mix used for men so we want to use
keywords closely related to one mix used
for men for example running shoes for
men or sport running shoes for men
outdoor sport shoes or air cushion shoes
let's take a look an example of amazon
so if i go to amazon i could see the one
mix shoes for men page and if i look at
this page i can see a lot of product and
each product has basically some content
associated with it i.e the title of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to
use different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sports shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker all
of these are lsi related keywords
they're similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different products so we want to make
the content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if you're e-commerce you want to make
sure that page is laid out properly easy
to read here i could see the descriptor
along with the title all kind of merge
together and so there's no breakout of
okay this is the product name this
description it's kind of one all-in-one
which i like it just makes it more
natural sounding okay and you can see
these are all broken out uh pretty well
laid out page and amazon is more or less
you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or a large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
page we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so if you have a web
page you sell products even if you don't
sell products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on amazon and we clicked on a product uh
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we can see
kind of the description well i may not
be so interested in buying this product
i want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
factor comes in where if i read other
reviews then i can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here i
could see that not only there are
reviews but there's testimonials so i
could see that here you can see that
there's a lot of stars and you can see
the kind of the review title these
running shoes are very comfortable and
lightweight so you have a lot of
different feedback and so reading
customer reviews is always helpful
because even though you're making the
decision it kind of will help sway you
in one direction or another at least it
does for me so that's the the beauty of
a customer review and a rating we want
to be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis so and
that goes for testimonials and reviews
you want to make sure you're always
getting reviews if you're always getting
reviews then that's just adding to the
particular product and so if you're
always updating your content on a
regular basis as well then google's
going to be able to see that and google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engage into the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to
amazon here we can see amazon lists a
lot of the benefits or one mix in this
case lists a lot of the benefits so here
you can see
all the descriptors about the particular
product it's got rubber sole it's got a
breathable textile lighting you get free
high quality socks with every shoe so
these are some of the features and if we
continue to scroll down we could see
some of the details about the fabric
type specifics about the fabric and a
lot of information on this product page
even a sizing chart so a lot of
different features that will help the
end user make the decision so don't hold
back add as much information as you
possibly can as much information as you
have available it doesn't hurt because
in the end what you're trying to do from
a product perspective is sell the
product and you can't really sell it
unless you have information that's going
to convince the user that this product
is what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if i
scroll down here i can see
some more of the benefits you know
waffle rubber outsole soft deodorant
insole
again fabric type it's got all sorts of
information it's got images about the
fabric itself the shoe itself how it's
structured so a lot of information about
this and it even does a comparison and
so there's a lot of information about
this particular product so don't hold
back add as much as you can to convince
the end user so in the case of the one
mix on amazon you know they had a sizing
chart you know they had an faq being
additional information what other
products that customers view from one
mix and then testimonials so these are
some of the basic bits of information
you want to add on your page if you
don't have custom reviews it's okay add
faq in its place again the end result is
to convince the customer to purchase the
product and then build a comprehensive
internal linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products so if i go back here
here i can see other products from one
mix so you should always have a linking
structure so that if the end user
doesn't want to particularly buy that
particular product then you have links
available so they can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product so
if we go back to our product page you
know they have different varieties that
they're showcasing here they have the
size chart they even have a size
convertible chart so if you're dealing
with metrics you can go over to us
metrics feet vice versa you can add a
video you know show a video of if you're
selling running shoes throw a video
somebody working out you know it doesn't
have to be a full-blown commercial per
se but it could be a short 30 second
video of what the shoe looks like on
somebody else's feet so that they could
see somebody walking with those shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you can do it right from your
phone so review your content before you
publish this goes without saying you
want to do that just you make sure you
include everything possible because when
the content does get published remember
google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for google as well we want to be able to
analyze
our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rate so this is important
because the meta tags i.e the title tag
in the meta description and the urls
what shows up in google search results
so we have title tags first that's the
first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when i say
modifiers i mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so
some tips for optimizing the title tag
in addition to modifiers we want to
watch the title length and we want to
include those target keywords in the
title tag so remember you're likely
going to have two keywords to work with
you want to have at least one of those
keywords in your title tag so with the
modifier you know up to 60 to 65
characters in length with that targeted
keyword should get you a good title tag
that's going to get somebody to click on
it so let's look at an example so if i
type in the keyword best recipes for
dried figs you know here i can scroll
down here's my title tag stands out my
url is right underneath that and
underneath the url are is the meta
description and so here i can see some
modifiers 188 best autumn dried fake
recipes or 25 fantastic fig recipes or
10 best cooking dried fig recipes so
these are all modifiers are going to
help somebody get the click get them to
click on your link and go to your
website so when you don't hit the 65
character limit if you go over that
google's going to cut off the title text
so we want to avoid that at all possible
so the whole idea is you know like 10
best cooking dried fake recipes by
yummly that's a good enticing title tag
okay takes into account a modifier
includes the targeted keyword and is
under the 65 character count some
additional tips for writing meta
description we always want to provide a
unique description for each web page of
the website so no duplicate meta tag
descriptions every page use needs to be
unique then we also want to be specific
about what we're offering so if you have
say you're selling headphones and you
have a particular set of headphones from
a different specific brand include that
in the meta description if you have that
particular product from that brand on
sale include that in the meta
description so you want to be as
specific as possible the whole idea
behind a meta description is to describe
the page but also to get the end user to
click on your link so here's an example
of using modifiers and describing a page
if we look at amazon again we can see
this example here and if we look at it
on google search results so if i type in
amazon bluetooth headsets ten dollars
are on sale here we can see a lot of
amazon listings in google search here
you can see the use of modifiers in the
title tag and also in the meta
description here we can see that you
know this particular headset bluetooth
headset is on sale 50 off so if
something's on sale feel free to include
it be descriptive about the page let
people know where they're going and use
those modifiers don't be afraid to use
numbers in the meta description even if
it's the price itself even if it's not
on sale but it is the price included
it's not going to hurt the more
information you can include in a meta
description the better chance you have
of somebody clicking on that link use
numbers symbols you know percentages off
always help use catchy words like
discount or cashback you're competing
with other listings on the page so if
you have something on sale if it's on
clearance list that it's on clearance
here i can see they even included the
coupon code so feel free to list as much
specific information about that page as
possible the whole idea is you're
competing with your own web pages but in
other cases with competitors so the meta
description along with the title tag and
the url helps separate out you from the
rest of the listings on search engine
results and we don't want to keyword
stuff we want to keep it within 160
something characters or 160 65
characters because google will break off
the meta description just like they do
with the title tag and so we want clean
natural written meta descriptions that
separate you from the competition so
that means including the keywords but
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if i
go back again to valleyfig.com and i
could see the meta description hey
welcome to the best resource online for
dried fake recipes savory is sweet
snacks are healthy dried food recipes
we've got it all okay start cooking with
figs and so it's natural sounding it
does include the keyword it's not
keyword stuffing it's natural sounding
that's hopefully going to get that
person to click on this particular
website let's turn our attention to
the url so we want to make sure that the
url
is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular url here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so
first of all i don't understand some of
it so that makes it unpleasant boring
and messy to say the least so you want
urls that you know basically are clean
and understandable so in other words we
want to make them seo friendly because
if they're seo friendly somebody
understands the url
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb is if you can
read the url then the search engines can
read the url so here are some tips for
creating friendly urls for seo make it
readable you want to include the target
keyword in the url so if it's dried figs
the oral should include dried figs if
it's dried fig recipes make sure it's
dried fig recipes now avoid using too
many subdirectories in the urls so we
want to keep it as close as possible to
the root directory and match the urls to
titles most of the time so let's go back
to our example here here we can see this
is valleyfig.com recipes not necessarily
dried fig recipes but recipes
nonetheless it's in the root directory
okay so at all cost now this is in some
cases unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an e-commerce website
that's calling you know content from a
database so if that is the case you're
going to have some dynamic parameters in
the url which is fine just make sure you
avoid having too many of those dynamic
parameters it's understandable that
parameters but the role of dumb
generally is no more than two different
parameters in the url so prefer to
create short urls that's really the way
to go the shorter the better is the rule
of thumb and you know if you're going to
break up the url then use hyphens
instead of underscores it's just cleaner
it's a more understandable search
engines tend to read it a little bit
easier if it's hyphen so here's what a
friendly url looks like for
search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's just a clean
url for a particular ecommerce site that
has categories and subcategories so
again we got amazon.com your category
can be electronics your subcategory
could be earphones and your product
could be both earphones it's that simple
let's start with talking about rich
snippets this is tip number four so we
want to add rich snippets to improve
your website's visibility on serps so
tip number four is all about rich
snippets so let's start out by asking
ourselves what is a rich snippet so rich
snippet is simply just a term used to
describe structured data markup that you
as a website owner can add to your html
so hypertext markup language or html is
what is basically constructs a page if
we can add more information to that that
will in turn allow search engines like
google to better understand the
information that's on that web page so
the more
google understands about that web page
the more they can put into the search
engine results page so rich snippets is
basically some structured data markup
that we can add to our existing html and
so if we want to add rich snippets to
search engines then how would you prefer
your products to be displayed well if we
have products then we want to make sure
that maybe we have reviews or maybe we
have so um other information in there
like links to our site okay so there's a
lot of different types of rich snippets
that you know we can add that google can
recognize and add to the search engine
results so if you have a product then
there's a lot of things we can add like
specifically product reviews so we want
to be able to add more information to
the search engine results by working in
some rich snippets so basically the
whole idea is to set up the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the serp
the more likelihood you're going to get
the click and the more likelihood that
click is specific traffic so some of the
benefits of structuring the data for
rich snippets are as i mentioned
increasing click-through rates you know
also increasing conversion rates so when
you get the traffic from organic search
to your website if somebody's looking
for specific product and you have a
number of different good reviews showing
up let's just say 5 stars out of 5 stars
and you have 100 reviews showing 5 stars
then you know somebody's probably going
to send take some trust in your brand
and your conversion rate probability is
going to go higher it also helps improve
your search engine visibility because
you're adding more information so in
other words the more google knows about
your page the likelihood it's going to
rank that page and it's more likely that
that information that's contained in
that rich snippet is going to get
featured in either the knowledge graph
which is that graph on the right side or
in a featured snippet which usually
shows up at the top of search engine
results so in other words the more
information you give google the more
they can use that information on their
search results page and there's no
disagreeing that the more information
that you have in your search engine
result the likelihood of getting more
traffic increases so for rich snippets
you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product pages the page itself
is an image you can always start there
you can always add a description you can
always add in ratings and you can always
add in reviews so these are some of the
most common attributes you can add as a
rich snippet so if you add that google
picks it up it's going to include that
information in the search results okay
some others are offers
prices site links links to your site and
product availability so all that
information can be conveyed to google
google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to ahrefs over
99.58 of featured pages that have
structured data already rank in the top
10 list of the google search results
page so in other words if you have rich
snippets in your page your chances of
ranking in the top 10 of a google result
is going to be very very very good okay
let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for a great
user experience so let's go over some of
the tips that you would do for planning
a good website for seo and so tip number
one
is you want a url structure that follows
your site's navigation hierarchy so
obviously home page interior pages so
depending on what type of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that site's navigation that's site
hierarchy and it all starts with the
home page you want to optimize your
homepage to drive traffic to your
product pages so the home page is
nothing more than a doorway into your
website and so the site's navigation
should link to all those different
products so if you have an e-commerce
site with sub-categories or categories
sub-categories then you want to be able
to
make sure your navigation reflects that
you want to build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking as well
because when you're from the home page
obviously you want to be able to easily
navigate to other pages however when
you're on other pages you want to be
able to have a link pointing back to
relevant pages and not necessarily on
the home page so this serves two
purposes one for the end user obviously
you want the end user to navigate
through your website seamlessly right
second for the search engines they're
following links they want to be able to
understand how your website flows and
links together so you don't want a
scenario where it's a one-way street
from the home page to interior pages you
want basically a home page to interior
interior to other relevant interior
pages and that could be a lateral
or that could be a situation where it's
a hierarchy for example home page
category subcategories sub sub category
etc you want to be able to make sure
your site is constructed in a manner in
which the search engine can read it so
css or cascading style sheets or
hypertext markup language html are your
two most common languages that's
basically what browsers load that's what
search engines like to index it just
makes it easy for them to understand
what your page is all about remember we
talked about rich snippets in the
previous tip rich snippets are nothing
more than supplemental html to describe
what the page is all about so that the
search engines can understand that page
and include reviews or include site
links in the search engine results so
this is all based on html so the more
you provide the search engines in a more
structured manner via html the more the
search engines are going to stay in the
page adding breadcrumbs to your product
pages is also a good practice if you
have an e-commerce site and you have a
category then a sub-category then a sub
sub category then a product page well
it's probably not a bad idea to make
sure you have a breadcrumb so that was
that way somebody can easily go right
back from the product page to say the
category page or to the subcategory page
directly without having to hit the back
button or having to go through the
navigation some good examples i think
amazon is a good example of using
breadcrumbs giving the amount of
products they have on their site so go
check out amazon if you want a good
example for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so a canonical
tag is nothing more than a link element
basically or an html element that
basically prevents duplicate content
issues so in other words if we have a
canonical tag as a meta tag basically
we're telling the search engines this is
the preferred or canonical version of a
web page okay so use this webpage so it
signals to the search engines which page
they should basically index and pay
attention to and avoid at all the other
pages that have similar content so
that's the idea behind a canonical tag
so that's a good best practice and then
optimize your site for desktop and
mobile i can't stress the mobile part
enough most users begin their journey on
mobile so
if you're not sure about what the search
engines like or don't like you can
always refer to google search console
for an example so if you go to google
search console they have a report called
mobile usability so if you click on
mobile usability you can see what pages
they like what pages they don't like
from a mobile perspective and if you
have errors they're going to tell you
what those errors are so if your website
has text that's too small to read
they're going to tell you that these are
the pages with this error and so that
allows you to go and address those
errors because from a google perspective
if you have if a page has a mobile
usability error then google will not
index that page so leverage google
search console to get a sense of what
type of errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when i say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your sitemap so when we talk about
sitemaps we want to make sure that it's
a file and xml file that basically
includes all of our urls and we can then
turn around and give that site map to
the search engines so if you have a
sitemap in xml make sure you go to
google search console so if i go to
google search console and i click on
site maps i can just simply just tell
google where my site map is located and
when they recognize that sitemap they're
going to be able to basically index the
urls from that sitemap so we can see
here how many urls they discover and how
many they index so make sure you create
the sitemap in an xml format submit the
sitemap via google search console and
then you can go back and see how many
pages they've indexed versus how many
you've submitted and you want to make
sure that sitemap is dynamic meaning
anytime you publish a url that url is
added to the sitemap fixing broken link
so broken links is not something you
want but it's something every website
has it's unavoidable you know people
publish pages all the time there's test
pages there's all sorts of reasons why
a site has broken links you want to be
able to address those and again going
back to google search console we can
basically see just by looking at some
reports what pages have broken links and
which ones don't so we could certainly
look at search console to get
information about basically what pages
are broken which ones aren't and then we
want to prefer predictive searches and
integrate product typographic errors on
your search bar so basically have a
search bar that's a best practice but
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
google analytics and looking at the
search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what i found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact i would
even go beyond sometimes most the time
again depending on your business but i
see most businesses now have live chat
enabled and so basically
having live chat enables somebody who
has a question to immediately reach out
to somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous gratification in some ways
so inserting live chat on a website is
more common practice than not nowadays
given it it lends to a better user
experience tip number six improve your
page speed and reduce the bounce rate so
let's talk about page speed and how page
speed correlates with higher bounce rate
if it's a high page load and so
according to crazy page speed is an
important overlooked seo tactic because
for every second delay and page load can
result in
fewer page views 60 decrease in customer
satisfaction
decline in conversion rate so you know
you can see here regardless of how
specific the numbers are when you have a
page that loads slow you're going to
have lower user engagement and a poor
user experience so you have to pay
attention to page speed and so since
2010 google has been using page speed as
a factor for page ranking in the search
engine results so here are some tips to
focus on making sure your pages are
optimal in terms of speed so
enable browser caching okay you can
reduce plugins if you're using wordpress
as an example you know disable plugins
you're not using getting using a simple
website design going back to tip number
five stick with css and html don't do
anything fancy in terms of technology
because it's only going to complicate
matters optimize your code minify files
meaning hey if you're not using any code
just get rid of it because code has to
execute and that slows down page load
time so if your website has numerous css
and javascript files basically minify
and combine them and that's what we're
talking about there you know you don't
necessarily need a lot of
you know javascript on your page you can
leverage google tag manager or you know
other features that help minimize the
number of javascript files you have and
so you can also get some of these ideas
by going into google analytics so in
analytics under behavior under site
speed under page timings you can
basically see how quick each page loads
and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so if we let this report
load we'll be able to see some speed
suggestions per page and so here you can
see for example the home page has an
average page load time of 4.89 seconds
you can see right next to that we have
page speed suggestions seven total so if
we click on that basically what it's
going to do it's going to launch another
google product called page speed
insights and what page speed insights is
going to do
is it's going to analyze the page in
question whether that be the home page
or an interior page and what they're
actually going to do is not only analyze
the desktop version of your website but
also the mobile version and so now we
can see opportunities to improve our
page speed by making sure the images are
properly sized making sure server
response time is changed again defer
unused css not using css that's or
getting rid of css or minifying it so
there's lots of things you can do and
again this is desktop and mobile so on
the mobile side we could see some of the
other issues too that are causing high
page load and so analytics site speed
reports page speed insights are good
ways to get an idea really excellent
ways to really address page load time
issues so again these are just some of
the common issues with page load time
there could be other factors leaning on
those page speed insights reports will
definitely help reduce page load time so
basically according to google a website
should have you know time to first bite
lesser than 200 milliseconds
milliseconds is very very fast so in
case your website is slower than 200
milliseconds such as 500 milliseconds or
more you need to improve it so you don't
even have to measure it by milliseconds
you can even go by seconds which is what
most of us count time and again you can
see that simply going into the speed
suggestions report in google analytics
so ideally in terms of seconds you want
something that's about
you know four seconds or less three
seconds or less obviously as fast as
possible so case study walmart walmart
reported the following results so
walmart experienced a two percent
increase in conversions for every one
second of page speed improvement so
think about that there's definitely
correlation between page load time and
speed so in conversions and user
engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement so with
that improvement they also experienced
an increment in revenue so meaning the
pages load people had a better user
experience they were able to check out
easier and that led to more revenue so
they were able to measure revenue
against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase the domain
authority of your website so google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page seo you need to
build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category pages or even content or blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
moz as a good tool to measure page
authority or domain authority so if i go
into moz moz has a page and domain
authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see what sites have
good domain or page authority just by
entering in the domain so relevant you
obviously want to rank to something
that's relevant so if you're in the food
industry something food related you want
to promote your content regularly on
social media so social media i always
consider it a whole low hanging fruit
when it comes to backlinking you know
there's so many different social media
platforms available facebook linkedin
twitter there's so many varieties from
images to pinterest and instagram to
video being youtube so there's lots of
ways to get your content out on social
media that will allow you to not only
promote your band build a community but
also establish a reference back to that
page you can opt for guest blogging okay
so you can reach out to another blogger
and blog on that platform and it could
be reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so
facebook's a good example it could be
you have any youtube channel if you're
into video you can certainly set up a
youtube channel build a following around
youtube as well so always start your own
page if that's the platform of choice
the last thing you should do is set up a
page on social media and not keep it
updated you could certainly participate
in forums you can participate in other
websites like cora or reddit that's very
you know content based content driven
user driven i always recommend starting
your own blog blog is a good way to not
only generate content but it's a good
way to incorporate different types of
content so you can set up different
types of content and categories it's a
good way to incorporate different assets
like images and video it's a good way to
get users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be a time constraint
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but creative
in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips so remember
tip number one we want to opt for
smarter ways to do keyword research so
remember we want to look at volume we
want to look at competition we want to
create themes put them in a spreadsheet
so we want to be smarter and which in
the way in which we choose our keyword
tip number two remember publish high
quality content to get more traffic when
we say high quality content remember
break up the content use different
assets organize it structure it you know
make sure it's answering some of these
questions then we talked about in tip
number three analyzing your meta tags
and urls so we want to make sure that
title tag meta descriptions are creative
use modifiers like numbers or promotions
you know we don't want to go over
character counts we want to make them
unique and distinct so that somebody
clicks on them then we talked about rich
snippets and tip number four remember
rich snippets are just additional html
that communicates the search engines so
the search engines can understand
exactly what's on your page so if you
have recipes if you have reviews if you
have videos if you have images if you
have ratings all these things can be
added to the serps just by communicating
with the search engines via rich
snippets tip 5 optimize your site
structure we want to make sure that you
know you have good inbound links you
want to make sure you incorporate
breadcrumbs you want to make sure users
can navigate your site more easily and
then in tip number six if your page is
load fast then it's going to enhance the
user experience it's going to increase
user engagement and increase conversions
and then tip number seven we want to
build quality link quality to increase
the domain authority so remember we can
use mods to measure domain authority
it's all about quality whether that be
via influencer marketing guest blogging
directories social media setting up a
social media page there's always
something you could be doing to generate
a quality link to your website thanks
rob with that we've reached the end of
this complete seo tutorial i hope you
guys enjoyed this video do like and
share it thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]
you